e
e e
what I so uh it being 9 o'
we'll open the finance division 2
meeting work
session
and uh I guess it makes sense to go
through these in the order that're on
the sheet right okay so let's open the
discussion on HB
506 and I'll throw it open to the
committee
papovich thank you Mr chair and good
morning to everyone um this seems to be
a I remember in the previous term uh
sitting in hearings on a similar Bill U
and it seems to be a bill that is just
trying to correct some U strange things
that were happening in the judicial
system around people whose Firearms were
seized or removed legally but then they
were no longer return it seems to be a
bill that has uh very very minimal uh
fiscal impact so I don't think we uh you
know have to do a lot of work on it I
would be comfortable with uh you know
just moving it forward if uh the
committee so
pleases any other coment Mur thank you
um I guess two questions um I guess you
know even reading this it's
tiresome I don't really understand the
nature of the problem and why division
one doesn't have this is it because this
is an issue that is um stuck in safety
is this where the the hiccup is I I
guess I would assume so but I leave it
to Mr we have the department here okay
does somebody from the Department want
to I don't know which department
safety you want to speak to why this is
in your department or whatever other
other questions you have for her
it's you're right I'm skipping that this
morning it is too early pull pull the
whole thing closer to you so that it's
there you go good morning
Representatives my name is Lieutenant
Mary cabriga I work for the Department
of Safety Division of State Police right
now I'm assigned to the records
Information Services which oversees the
permits and Licensing unit um right now
the return of firearms we get all the
civil cases that come through the
department of safety we don't get the
criminal cases go go through their local
jurisdiction so this would now change it
that all these return of firearms would
come directly through the department of
safety by this
bill so so that's one of the impacts of
the bill itself correct
okay yes if I may just better understand
thank you for being here and answering
questions um when you say they come to
you the returns of firearms you you
don't mean the physical return of
firearms you just mean the decision or
the you know red light green light type
uh question cuz the way I understand it
and I would appreciate if you correct me
if I understand it incorrectly this bill
requires that once the order uh you know
that was relevant to the seizing expires
the Firearms should be returned
immediately it waves the requirement for
the court to ask for a background check
but if a background check is asked then
it falls into the lap of the Department
of Safety so when you talk about this
becomes a department of safety you are
talking about the background checkpoint
and the yes it's okay no it's not okay
decision not the not anything else or
like the physical possession of the
Firearms or anything no we do not house
the Firearms unless of course State
Police took those into custody but other
than that yes the local PDS would still
hold those we just do the background
check thank you for clarifying yeah
yes um I think right now criminal goes
through you civil does not is that what
you said opposite
civil and so this would allow criminal
to go through you correct both go
through you okay I got it I wasn't
sure you want to make a motion over on
the side I was just trying to allow for
all necessary discussion by the
committee but since uh we are already
here I would like to make an OTP motion
for HB 506 FN
further
discussion call the role Madam all the
RO all
right OTP
OTP um representative papovich I okay
representative Bean yes representative D
Roy
yes representative Wilder are you voting
today yes
representative yes if
you're I well I thought i' just asked
make sure representative hacken Phillips
yes I'm getting that that's it it took a
while okay
and we have a motion uh to OTP did you
call Representative party I thought I
did oh she did me she didn't do earth oh
I didn't do you again I always miss you
I don't know why would you like to vote
uh yes I like to vote and I vote Yes
that is so funny as a general guideline
the only person sitting at the table
that doesn't vote is Mr landrier so
we'll I'll get him in there too I'm sure
at some point in time yes the motion
moves 7 to
zero thank you thank you thank you for
coming this morning I appreciate it
thank you
I have to keep banging this thing but
I'll close the hearing on uh HB
506 and open the hearing on not hearing
work session excuse me on HB
671 establishing a kindergarten literacy
right in this
program and open it to discussion we
have folks here from the Department if
we need them okay
any comments from
the Galler take your time we're moving
along just
fine I'm just wondering do we um maybe
someone could give us a little
historical knowledge of what happened
through committee and the floor to how
it reached us any if anyone knows I I
can tell you I can't tell you any of
that but I can tell you that like the
last one both of these were passed on
the consent calendar two weeks ago
despite they're having money in them and
I did actually make reference or discuss
that with the with the uh Clerk and he
apologize but they don't take
responsibility for that it's basically
on the Committees that that put them on
there but if we have somebody from the
from the um relevant
committee that knows more that'd be
great relevant Department
sorry I was G to say Melissa white
division director for larner support
department of education and so um when
this had gone to uh the committee they
passed it the um Department came in and
testified that the dollar that is
allocated for this is not sufficient so
I think that of course um I think I
heard the word
we'll let we'll let Finance figure that
out so here we
[Laughter]
are um oh a favorite line this program
was a contract that the department
engaged in during uh the pandemic
utilizing the covid-19 pandemic relief
funds uh at that time the department was
looking at ways to support families
remotely I think that this was like 200
2021 is um and we were looking for ways
to augment supports for preschool or um
kind of that birth to to five range um
supports at home for families so we did
partner with Waterford to
provide these supports for families um
at that time the cost for the
contract was about $600,000
per
year so now that the covid-19 funds we
of course no longer have those funds we
um the contract ended I believe about a
year ago so that program ended
and that's kind of where we're at with
this I believe that it was the um
Waterford program that was working
to um create this legislation so I'm
definitely here to answer any questions
about the contract with the Department
um I think there's somebody here from
Waterford that has maybe more
information on I guess the type of
programming they're envisioning but I'm
I'm just here to provide background
information on the contract and then the
dollar that is
appropriated um we would not if it was
if it were to pass we would not be able
to execute what's in the can't believe
that a representative wer
sorry was it in fact ever ever used this
contract was it used during covid thank
you for the question so we did have
families that were engaging in using it
I think the difficulty is that we were
not able to Garner
um more data on the usage on the
engagement and particularly on a pre and
post outcome to see how you know how it
where the situation where families were
at the beginning and then the engagement
process and then what the outcomes were
we don't have any information on that so
I think that is something that
um would be important if we were to look
at going
forward If This Were to pass if it were
properly funded then we would do um an
RFP for this work because I think while
it was a specific vendor that we worked
with to do this work we would still have
to go through the the state's
procurement process and do a request for
proposals based on the criteria that's
written in the legislation review those
proposals and ensure that we are
selecting uh a vendor that can provide
evidence-based research and some uh data
to support so that was not in this
contractor to provide some data that
whether we found that this was effective
or not we had the numbers of of uh usage
but it wasn't the pre- and post outcomes
we didn't have that information do we
know the number of usages that I can get
to you because we're being asked to put
some more money in it obviously
600,000 with no results and no answer of
whether that money was properly spent
it's hard to say yeah throw some more
money at it correct thank
you is that maray thank you you
referenced Waterford correct so this
money went to this one particular area
this one school district this was not
Statewide Waterford was a vendor that
provided the support the vendor the
vendor yes that provided the supports
but it was family Statewide so any
family so it was Statewide that could be
could access the services so this was
open to All Families thank you for
clarifying that I misunderstood so um
this was part of the pandemic when the
schools were closed correct in order to
provide Readiness tools or you know
access for Kinder um schools are now
open again correct so if the schools are
open who's going to be using it this
time apparently would be a far far not
not so many kids maybe or do you expect
this to go a program that goes into the
schools thank you for the question so
the the program is aimed at the
preliteracy so it's those kids that are
zero to five before they've entered
school so I think that that
um and I can't speak to put the
legislation together and drafted this my
understanding is that it's to aim at
those still that same zero to five
before they've entered school as sort of
an augment and I think it's a an
online type of service or or program
that the student or the kids engage in
not really students at that point their
kids that Areo we're looking at Nursery
schools or dayc carees or home schools
correct at students that are not in
kindergarten yet yes correct thank
you repr
papich thank you Mr chair I I will say
first that I'm not a fan of $1
Appropriations but that's not for
anybody in this room it's uh you know
something that I will Express in the
appropriate context too um my question
is in regards to the part of the bill
that refers to uh meeting tier one
benchmarks under the us doe
Essa um does that indicate that we
expect to get any federal funds or is
just that something that we need to
comply with regardless of whether we get
paid or not we will not have any federal
funds that could possibly go towards
this there so would you know why then
there are references to the tier
benchmarks I understand it's not your
bill I get it but what's your best guess
in terms of the intent of requiring that
correct that piece of it I I do not
thank not clear on no I appreciate it uh
if I may continue for a sec look I I'm
looking at this and I'm kind of
scratching my head unofficially here um
at this point in time I would probably
suggest that something that
uh at best we can retain and uh see what
we can do about it but I don't I don't
see how based on what we have at this
time we can make a more aggressive
decision on this both because of the
funding questions and also
because it's kind of unclear how
necessary this is at this point in time
and I I I'm open to getting more you
know EV evidence and testimony on this
but there doesn't seem to be anybody
else in the room that is prepared to do
that at this time there is excellent oh
see I miss that then I would like to
wait and just one last if I may the
department right now is engaging and
doing A needs assessment for literacy
we're working on um updating our state
literacy plan that hasn't been done in
many many years and so part of that
literacy plan and that needs assessment
is really diving into more data as far
as what are the needs and we will look
at what are the needs from that zero to
five range and that preschool range what
are the needs in you know K to five what
are the needs and then we're looking at
middle school and high school and so to
form formulate that plan it's taking
some time to get all of our stakeholders
and different constituents engaged with
that assessment but part of that is
looking at okay what are the needs and
then kind of having that plan Drive the
pieces that we would kind of put
together to meet those needs so while
this um work is very very important for
that 0 to five range I I do want to just
um let this committee know the
department is engaging and working on
doing something more comprehensive um so
we can see what the needs are Statewide
and then kind of come up with a plan to
to meet those needs do you have any kind
of time frame for that um I think we
plan to have it finished by the end of
the year calendar year correct thank you
uh representative uh Dy you said that
you haven't done A needs assessment in a
long time what what normally would you
be doing I assume Co interrupted a lot
of that and but do you do a needs
assessment especially on liter
where our children are not learning so
with the the Statewide literacy plan it
really was based many years ago before
we were really delving into the science
of reading with all the new research
that has come out specific with science
of reading and how to teach literacy
particularly at that zero to you know
fifth grade range uh our plan is
reflective of of a kind of an older
older thought process and and an older
pedagogy regarding literacy so I think
that now we're looking at it needs to be
updated because it has to include that
more updated information and then we
would take our current assessment data
to kind of dive into that with the also
legislation that is passed with
dyslexia um in the past couple of years
we're able to Garner some more
information and data there to see what
those needs are because that really does
feed in I mean that 0 to five uh year
old range does feed into that uh that
dislike
um supports and and kind of identifying
those students that need that help
wonder prior to going to school thank
you chairman wer I would move that we
retain the bill and wait to hear more
information I'm sure that Waterford
should have run some data they would
like to know how many tablets or
anything they handed out or whether they
this was just a matter of here's the
website go on it and try to use it for
your child rather than us having to hand
out computers thank
you I'm going to if I may second this
for the purpose of
discussion um would you be willing yes I
don't know your name but would you come
for you can stay there might as well
have you both here no no come on up to
the microphone please and then introduce
yourself
and and pull the whole thing closer to
you so that it's right by your mouth
right there there you go perfect thank
you to Isa Rosenberger um good morning
all of you I work for Berns Shore and I
represent Waterford um upstart let me
just give you a little quick background
on this uh Bering Shore was hired by
Waterford oh way long while back
Waterford had gotten a contract with the
city of nashwa to do prek kindergarten
Readiness program that program had been
funded by the United Way of national
I think some City money Etc and it was
specifically to Target kids going to um
beginning kindergarten and NASA was
targeted because of the population in
NASA that program was tremendously
successful and to represent Wilder's
question Waterford does an assessment at
the beginning of the program and at the
end of the program and so when that
program was done the results
particularly for those children who were
new Americans and and Etc was tremendous
um and also lowincome kits so at that
point um the state through the
Department of Education and the
commissioner after that got a Fed a
grant through it was a federal Grant if
I remember through UNH could you
possibly just include time frames when
you as you're talking so we know when
this is actually occurring years that
kind of thing oh gosh you know I have a
brain injury that's going to really push
me but that's ripped into wild and no so
you know the short long ter well anyway
approximate not like let me just say my
first final report for the year is 2022
23 and then I have 20 20 um 3 24 so I
think um frankly let me think the
pandemic was what
2020 I think the national program was
about 2020 and I think we got the um
Federal the Grant from through UNH I
think maybe 21
22 I don't have these covid-19 pandemic
relief funds right but it came the grant
we got came through UNH to DOA and and
um that was for Statewide Waterford
started in 2008 in Utah and it has gone
all across the country and what
Waterford does it was designed to go in
to the home and it was specifically
designed to engage the parents so the
idea was you go in the home they give
the child a computer if they do not have
a computer they also provide internet if
they don't have an internet connection
with doe and any program they've done
Waterford this is a private public
partnership and waterers perap and that
they contribute the computer they
contribute the internet the state can't
do that so they do it so um the idea was
to go in and engage the parents as well
in this 15 minutes of
um coaching tutoring every day it's
supposed to be 15 minutes 5 days a week
and there is a coach that is working
with the family and monitoring so
there's a coach that's watching that's
saying wait this child is really not
picking it up here but they are here so
so and the coach works with the family
and I think in the beginning they found
that the coach called one family and
said it's supposed to be two 15 minutes
a day you're doing two hours what turned
out that the adult in the house who'
only gone through the eighth grade was
taking the program as well and that was
particularly happening with some
families that English was not the first
language so the program so when we got
the state Grant the state Grant was
specifically for targeted so we have to
go to your house we have to go to your
house we have to go to your house we're
not we were not going to prek schools or
any of that that's why Divine Mt got
hired because they needed somebody to
say can you introduce us in Berlin to
somebody who would be able to access
those people directly finding each
person that has a three or four year old
all is Pretty Tough so we got hired to
do that not to come in here just to
really basically open doors and and and
Etc so during the process they hired a
gentleman named Rob Riley and I'm sorry
he's not here today but he's on medical
leave who was the director of the YMCA
in Rochester Rob came in as basically
the community coordinator and Rob ended
up getting a number of not only Public
Schools but also um daycare prek Nursery
schools to take the program um the doe
approve approved that and said okay yes
you can do it in a school setting so for
example it's done in Dairy and Derry has
a program where it's a pre where where
when we go in and in that case there 12
or 13 kids in the class we're still
doing the 15 minutes we're still doing
the coaching we're just getting a bigger
group of kids at one time instead of
going to your house your but we are
still doing the oneon-one in the Humes
the goal is still to engage the families
and even in Dairy they're engaging the
families uh London Dairy we talked to
London Dairy because they don't have uh
full day kindergarten they have half day
and they really felt like one they
needed to um they needed to have their
prees up up to smed and then they wanted
to know if Waterford could actually do a
program to supplement the kindergarten
in the afternoon 15 minutes again which
they said yes they were going to use
your opioid abatement funds because the
way they read those guidelines
prevention was in there unfortunately
the Attorney General's office said no so
that did not that did not happen but
that again was a wonderful application
um Waterford does do the assessments
it's all uh I'm not sure because I don't
interact with doe on this I'm not sure
if that had been communicated to you I
know Christine Brennan the assistant
commissioner At Doe is totally involved
in this and probably the best champion
in the state I know there's we were
weekly calls with her with Waterford so
I'm and I think the information was
probably um was probably sent in I think
she probably has it this bill came in
and let me be very clear there will be
an RFP
yes will order for it apply yes will
others apply yes as far as we're
concerned if somebody else gets it gosh
we would like to have it because we've
started the work but if we don't get it
the bottom line is children are ready to
go to kindergarten there are studies out
there that when kids are ready to learn
particularly in kindergarten at
kindergarten through three they learn
and they don't go off the grid and you
don't have the issues that you have
later po particularly with alcohol and
drugs Etc because kids can't read or
they can't learn so this is not for
Waterford yes we would apply yes we put
it in the program ended uh with the last
school year because there was not
funding for this current school year we
had over we proba probably had 700 kids
in the pipeline you'll see from this
report um the numbers are right around
500 478 450
um Etc but we had kids in the pipeline
to do it the kids are still there um
which is why we put the legislation in
to be perfectly blunt the reason a
dollar's in there was we knew you had a
tough budget but more
importantly we thought if the state puts
this impra on some sort of
preek Readiness then it would give us a
better shot at going to some nonprofits
because the state says this important
but the state also says we have a budget
crisis and can't fund it so maybe
somebody could could get us there the
program costs about $1,100 a child now
Waterford with that the Waterford is
still giving the computer and the um
internet access to those who don't have
it when the program finishes for a child
and they go to kindergarten they keep
the laptop or TBL
but they do not continue with the
internet we stop the internet once the
kid the child has finished and we do try
to Target directly so as far as we're
concerned if you love to have you pass
the policy you can make it zero and put
a line in there that says if we need a
line in there that we can get uh
contributions um if you'd like to fund
it we'd be thrilled but I'm not going to
with what you've got going on um I know
you know we'd love it to stay in So at
the end of the day if in may you all
find a half a million dollars a quarter
of a million dollars I mean we'd love a
million dollars but you know if you find
a little chain sitting around we'd love
to have it funded so that's that's I'm
sorry I did a dump on you but that's
that's the whole thing that was great
thank you you held up a couple of
documents there I'll be happy to give
them to you and I you don't do it right
now but that that'd be great if you get
those and also the has to go with them
the actual original electronic file yes
I to Mr andan is the person to do that
I'll give yes represent papich y I'll be
happy to do that it's one of those cases
where I'm in just my second term and I
genuinely don't know whether we my gut
feeling is we cannot just pass a
legislation and say gez this would be a
good idea we're going to pass a law
saying it has to happen but we cannot
put money in it it will only happen if
uh donors come in so I would appreciate
some feedback back from the more
experienced members of the committee or
from anybody who may know on whether
that's even an option I do know because
I did some research on this there are
other statutes that actually
particularly pertain to doe and you may
know B more than I that have said fun
when Appropriations are
available so you know again that is the
policy and and as as you know uh the
policy education committee passed it 18
to zero and it was own consent in the
house so it's saying we'll fund it when
there's money and I can get you those
references too representative wer when
the uh new doe is created or doe is
eliminated and it everything comes out
just in
Grants then there's a little more
flexibility I one of the things I like
about this is parent involvement what
I'm hearing from the people who are
teaching is the parents don't get
involved in the kids's uh education
except to complain to the teacher why
did you give him a d because he didn't
do any work um well you should have done
made him do the work you know this is
this is the idea the parents nowadays
aren't what they used to be that they
took part in the kids' education I like
the fact that the parents are involved
but you know they we given them a tablet
they could turn around and sell it or or
misuse it who knows um there ought to be
some
either a co-pay or a deposit or some
sort of thing that there's some respect
for this everybody has to have skin in
the game or it's meaningless you got a
get a tablet for nothing oh good maybe I
can swap it for something instead of
using it for what it's intended for um
especially when we're dealing with
people that hardly read and write
themselves um it it's a good idea if it
works um it's risky to to to be handing
out tablets and and things that and and
have them do they really spend 15
minutes a day this is for population
that isn't very disciplined anyway
that's why they're low-income they don't
show up at work they don't do what
they're supposed to do um you know this
is this is the experience I've had with
low-income people the money goes for
cigarettes and beer but anyway I think
it's it's worth retaining because maybe
we'll find some money thank you up time
muray yeah this is I think um the policy
committee has already looked at this and
supported it and I think that we support
their policy um and you know you you
already know there's just not probably
going to be any money but um I do think
it's a good idea to hold on this to give
you know that we support the work that
the policy committee did on this so I'm
very fine with the
retaining and may I just answer I forgot
to answer your question about the um the
standards here here that was only put in
so that it whoever the state chose was
living up to those those national
standards of of a program for literacy
nothing to do with with the with the um
the federal it's just unfortunately yeah
yeah yeah yeah thank you Mr J repres PHS
um I'm just looking at um page two of
the language of the bill down at the
bottom regarding the Corporation it it
appears that the this has language that
would allow warrants to be drawn from
the general fund so am I correct in
understanding that this might be
something that the department could
potentially go to the fiscal committee
to no okay how would that work m
key so for every appropriation of
General funds that standard warrant
language is there this is specific to
that dollar okay so this this is
allowing the governor to draw the dollar
warrant
I appreciate the answer but now I am
confused um because the language says
draw a warrant from the Jour fund for
any sum not otherwise oh sorry I got I
just answered my own question it's money
that's available in the general fund but
cannot exceed the $1 sometimes we think
allow thank
you we do um yeah we have early motion
yeah yeah we there and
other
discussion I I guess one thing I would
ask is that maybe you come forward with
uh language I assume you're an attorney
I get that
sense oh okay but related to attorneys
or not related to them but work with
them um with the kind of language you
that would Implement what you just
described where we don't provide any
money but we provide the impr prometer
so we understand exactly what you mean
and what potential ramifications that
has for the state yes I will be happy to
do that and is it all right if I include
language in there that would allow
donations you can provide whatever you
like to provide I'm not guaranteeing
anything but the more information you
provide better I'll I'll give you
options yeah that'd be fantastic yes and
I also would say just to answer you
representative wer um because they're
coaches they're monitoring what happens
on those tablets and I think whoever
gets the contract water forgives tablets
now I don't know if the others there are
n profits out I don't know if everybody
the others were out there give a tablet
and certainly if it's you know that can
be a discussion between doe and and and
whoever gets it as to whether there's a
co-pay or not but thank
you any other
discussion all right um when you're
ready Madam clerk you can call the
rooll representative papovich one just
one moment thank you both for coming if
if you're splitting real quickly I
really appreciate your help both of you
thank
you goodbye thank you okay the motion of
itl on the table retain oh retain I'm
sorry oh retain that's a good idea that
we do this again thank you retain right
Mr chair I oh go ahead there there is
also a Health and Human Services
component to this bill a very small one
but uh if you look at the note they did
Identify some potential cost I don't
know if you want to hear from the
Department oh they're here as well yeah
sure come on up I don't know who's who
and I'm sorry I should recognize you all
but I don't
yet yeah but I've been
in uh please introduce yourselves and uh
provide us what whatever information
You' like to provide us thank you hi uh
Brian Clark I'm uh general counsel for
the division of economic stability and I
have with
me hi I'm Rebecca Lorden Finance
director for Dees and
DCF so just to
clarify um neither of you is with DHHS
no we're we're both with DHHS I'm sorry
I I identified the division uh not the
division of economic stability is part
of the Department of Health Human
Services sorry right thank
you um so the proposed legislation
requires the Department of Health and
Human Services to notify approved um
Wick and tanif recipients that have an
age appropriate child that being a four
or five-year-old of the existence of
this program um and so to specifically
notify them we we put in the fiscal note
the cost of sending out a
mailing and we just wanted to point out
there's no appropriation to cover
that any questions from the
committee I I'm just again trying to
understand exactly what the DHHS would
do for this particular U Bill and
whether you know any significant amount
of effort or costs or staff may be
involved so it's an automated we um so
there would be um so there's two
programs uh the temporary assistance for
needy families and the women's infant
and children's programs that would need
to notify uh the applicants and
recipients with the age appropriate
child so on the temporary assistance for
needy families on the tanif side um
there's a computer system that sends out
mailings to um households that notifies
them of different changes with their
case and so the cost on that side is to
make changes to that computer system uh
to send out a mailing when either
someone whose age appropriate is
approved or when someone becomes four
years
old um and then on the wick side um
there isn't a computer system so it
would be having staff send out that
notification thank
you it would seem you would be in in
touch with these clients all the time
anyway that's correct there shouldn't be
an additional thing it could be added on
to monthly contacts or whatever however
you contact these people so the the way
the proposed legislation was worded was
notifying um
specifically recipient
that have these age appropriate children
and so we don't have a way to filter
that
out um that would so it's it's not as
simple as attaching it to a notice of
decision if you wanted it to
be something that we just published the
information that this is available that
would go out to people who don't have
age appropriate
children that would seem to be almost
zero cost thank
you so from the point of view of the
department if the legislation is
modified to say that instead of
filtering the specific people who are
eligible and just sending them a special
letter for this if you'd include a you
know little language on every letter you
said to every you know tan Tanny family
saying hey if you have a kid of this age
there is this program that's available
would that save you cost because instead
of you know you you just have to change
a form letter that you are sending to
them instead of querying the database
for them getting the list out preparing
a mailing list and sending in a paying
postage for a special letter just
looking for every way to continue to
achieve the goals of the legislation
while saving funds because again tough
budget and all
um yes I believe so um if we were to
attach it to a mailing that already goes
out or if we were to publish it on our
website
um the website definitely has no cost
the the mailing could potentially be an
impact um but if it's unlikely thank you
Cuz look I'm I'm concerned that be
obviously the website is nice and we all
like to think that everybody goes to the
website but fact is that lots of people
don't and I don't want to just post it
in the you know website and have a bunch
of families never go there because they
don't realize they should but if we just
not even include a special leaflet but
put you know language at the bottom or
in in part of the letter that they get
that hey now that you are eligible for
this you know you are also you may also
be eligible for this if you have a in
this age range would in your opinion
that you
know really change cost much obviously
there will be one time cost to
redesigning the letters the forms and
everything I get that but in terms of
recurring costs which are more of my
concern you know one time course you pay
them once you're done you know you move
on but recurring stuff tends to pile on
so I'm just looking for anything that
would notify everybody but keep the
recurring cost to a minimum
representative Murray thank you yeah I'm
in a loop about the same thing because
it says notify any approved applicants
for either and then you know it goes on
from there um and I'm wondering how does
a family know whether or not they're
approved it seemed like yall would be
involved early on because you already
have that information about whether
they're part of these programs or not
and so I I was sort of I think making
the assumption that one way they would
find out about the program would be
through information that you had already
sent them do you know what I'm trying to
say is how how do they know even apply
to the
program that that the program exists
where do they first get word of the
program and if it's for some of these
people it seems like that would come
from you initially um it's not like are
they going to call a Department of
Education and say got anything so do you
see I'm lost in the loop here right so
um to answer your question I'd like to
uh clarify when you refer to the program
you're referring to the kindergarten
literacy program yes sorry thank you
okay so they would already be so someone
a family would apply for temporary
assistance to needy families or Wick
with the Department um and then we would
send them we would um look at their
eligibility and whether they meet the
program requirements and then send them
a notice of decision that says you're
eligible here's your benefit um and
there's more information to it
but yes that's that's what we would do
um and
so the this proposed legislation
specifically said notify these
households with age appropriate children
so we took that to mean if a temporary
assistant a TANF case opens and they
have a
one-year-old we wouldn't send a notice
about this literacy program to them but
then when that um one-year-old turns
four we
would I said yeah that um that seems
workable and I don't see that being a
really heavy lift from your point isn't
it sort of just another paragraph and
once you've identified that says and you
know in addition to this and this and
this you might look at this program as
well so for for tanif it's the cost of
um changing the computer system to track
that this language gets added for these
cases
that are uh have a four or fiveyear
old so we could change that and none of
this is fixed right and we probably
won't be looking at this for a while
anyway represent you have I just I just
wanted to make sure that we are all on
the same page CU my understanding of the
language on the top of page two Roman
numeral 4 that I think we were talking
about it says availability of the
Adaptive Kinder if the applicant
indicates that he or she has at least
one child who would qualify because of
age so my understanding is that the
approved applicants refers to people who
are approved into you know the Tanny for
week right that was my understanding
right so that would be before the even
are aware there is a kindergarten
assistance program so once they are
approved into that program the
department the DHHS would then have the
obligation to tell them hey by the way
this other program is also available so
you know it's it seems to be that early
notice but I'm I'm just not sure
if notif trying to wait until they are
foreign notified
then is cause Justified but I guess
that's something we'll discuss later I
think we're in a good place yeah no I
think for now we've gotten as much as we
needed to get okay representative wer
we're all referring to it as tan which I
appreciate I see it's been changed to
Financial assistance to needy families I
like the having the idea of temporary on
that so people don't just say how much
am I going to get But realize that this
isn't going for Generations this is
temporary you're supposed to go and get
a job and improve yourself so I hope
this hasn't officially been changed to
fanth um so uh temporary assistance for
need families is the name of the Federal
grant um and then the state had is the
financial assistance for needy families
is the state name for um wrong
okay okay any other discussion do we
have a motion yes retain okay second
have we voted we
were we try to vote
already I wrote down the
answer all right Madam clerk will
okay we have a motion to retain uh
representative papichi I I
representative Bean yes representative D
Roy yes representative chair wer or
yes
representative uh Mary yes
representative hacken Phillips yes
representative F there you go yes all
righty sorry for the confusion on my
side so motion moves 70 thank you and
thank you both for coming as well can I
get her last name spelled for me please
um this young
lady Lorden l o rde n thank you I
appreciate that you're welcome
I'm sorry what was the
question uh CL a r
k all righty I'll close the work session
on HB
671 and open the work session on we can
probably do these together but we'll do
one at a time uh HB 494 relative to the
math learning communities program and
making an appropriation there and I'll
recognize uh Shannon uh gosh I can't
last name re Reed the representative
from ccsnh thank
you good morning Shannon Reed rid
representing the community college
system of New Hampshire um thank you for
consideration of hit for 94 the house um
education funding committee passed this
bill with a an amendment this bill
contains two parts section one is
language which updates existing
statutory language on the mouth learning
communities program section two is the
appropriation um to continue um the our
ability to offer this this program math
learning communities is a partnership
between the community college system of
New Hampshire and New Hampshire High
Schools it brings together Math teachers
from both levels across the state to
kind of convene a community of practice
and develop a curriculum and two courses
that are designed to help students in
high school who are struggling with math
and who are at risk of not graduating
from high school with um appropriate
levels of math attainment for
post-secondary education and um and and
use in careers um this has been a very
successful program in the past um we
have
uh many high schools that are that are
engaged in this right now with us the
the high school teachers and the college
teachers really appreciate the ability
to kind of work together um share share
wisdom and ideas and Innovation and
develop courses that um are really aimed
at really kind of pitched at this that
the student who has struggled in math
and we do not want to see high school
students graduating from from high
school with with math that's that's
really that doesn't serve them well in
in their future so that's really what
this program is aimed at so as I said
the policy committee has has passed this
bill I think you have a number of
options before you as as far as what to
do with it I would say a couple of
things um the appropriation is currently
in the governor's House Bill 2 so that's
before you in that in that budget the
language is not in House Bill 2 this
this language in section one is quite
important in just updating the the
program from when it it ran initially to
when it was sort of relaunched two years
ago what's in statute right now is is
old and it's also very specific and
detailed
about course content and curriculum and
that's really not I I don't think you
want that level of specificity in
statute because as things evolve we're
going to want the the latitude to kind
of make sure that the programming
evolves as well so I would say whatever
you can do to preserve the language uh
would be really important to us perhaps
you
could strip the appropriation from this
bill and pass the bill so that we know
the language is going through the
appropriation already sits in House Bill
2 so that's one option um I'm sure I'm
sure Mr Lander can outline other other
um sound options for this and I'm happy
to answer any questions thank you rob
papovich not a question but a quick note
having sat in the uh you know uh policy
committee for this um the only reason
why the Appropriations below the
governor's recommendation is that this
is a very tight budget here and the
policy committee was U aware of that an
understanding of that but honestly if
there is any place where we can shake
some new money this is one of the places
where I would like to prioritize and in
terms of the language obviously uh we I
I I would be happy to try to accommodate
whatever uh you know is best so that the
program is uh properly you know
supported by legislation and
Appropriations and whatnot thank you
thank you very much and of course
another option is to take this language
and put it in hpit to that's probably
the best um the best way to make sure
that it goes forward one way or the
other other questions
comments yeah on if I may ask Mr
landrian on his opinion on the best way
to handle the language because to me it
kind of feels that may be stripping all
of Appropriations and passing the bill
to have the policy and then worrying
about the Appropriations in you know the
budget itself may be more stable for the
program than putting it in hb2 where it
may need to be again in hb2 and so on
but obviously could you please
comment I I think that's a pretty good
option to just strike section two of the
bill pass section one have this go uh
all the statutory changes on its own as
part of House Bill 494 and just consider
funding the program when you consider
ccsnh H's budget as part of house bill
one and
two strike section was that two uh two
yeah the appropriation section and then
pass all the statutory changes that the
policy uh committee
approved I'm comfortable with that just
saying out
loud so essentially OTP minus the
section two is that so what the
committee could do is an otpa knowing
that I'm going to be drafting an
amendment to delete section
two but then we don't we'd want to OTP
that an otpa that am yeah yeah okay any
other discussion can I just represent
muray otpa so the so I need to draft an
amendment to delete section two so the
amendment is to hb2 no it's to House
Bill 494 to delete section two we're
going to amend the pass the bill without
it we're going to recommend OTP and put
it on the calendar and get get it out of
here when does it get into hb2 it
doesn't this part of it doesn't Okay the
language would the language would move
forward under the bill but the
appropriation would be in hb2 if I'm
understanding correctly oh hb1 sorry oh
sorry what a day it to be determined
where the so the governor funded this in
house bill one historically this has
been funded in house bill to when we get
to cc's budget as far as House Bill one
and two the committee can decide how you
want to fund it at what level repres and
if I may I I just want to remind
everybody that this is an recommendation
to the overall committee so the fact
that we don't have the amendment in
front of us is fine because in the past
we've never had an issue with it and
we'll have time to review the amended
bill when it's discussed in front of the
full committee if God forbid a com out
the place we'll have an opportunity to
find it so we should be good
seriously the whole moving this out of
hb2 I don't think this is you know
something that necessarily needs to be
there and um you know it will cut the
size of hb2 a little which is kind of
nice I thought that she requested some
changes in in in the statements here
that would change it a little bit the
changes we requested have already been
made they're part of House Bill 494
section one that contains our changes
but if it come so if we ought to pass
the changes will go through anyway it
don't need to be in hb2 thank
you okay now I'm
confused house fille 494 as it comes as
it came to the policy committee and as
it comes to you contains section one
which is which are the changes we I I
get that okay but you then you tied that
back to hp1 is is there is some of that
language already in hp1 you the only
thing
hb1 is the funding for this into hospit
all right so the language would only be
here once we amend this the policy
language will only be in this bill that
we're going to send back to the house as
amended by what represented of Mr L said
yes you you could
also move the section one language not
move you could also add the same
language that's in section one to House
Bill 2 to have it in two places but I I
you know I don't know if that makes the
most sense okay we can talk about that
in in the future but and now you're
talking about the same language we
sending forward in the bill you you say
you want us to consider putting that in
hb2 in addition to the Appropriations
wherever we may put them that's that's
one option okay I guess we we we really
want this language change passed y so it
strikes me that getting 494 sort of
clean so it can go from the house to the
Senate without
without a price tag attached to it is is
probably the best way to just move this
forward okay delete section strike
section
two not talk about
hb2 no
seriously okay go ahead I just wanted to
say that separating the language from
the appropriation just simplifies our
work we can get the language off the
table and just focus on the numbers so
well we'll
see um any other
discussion so does somebody want to make
that motion who about to pass as
amended second and I'll just add with
the amendment being to strike section
two from HP 494 which is the
appropriation to be
determined section on page
we had a second
by all right so we have a motion on the
floor
GP
represent I representative yes
representative D yes representative
chair
yes
yes yes
don't go
[Laughter]
anywhere all right so I will close the
work session on HB
494 and open the work session on HB 716
making an appropriation for the Dual and
concurrent enrollment program and I'll
welcome Miss Reed back Mrs Reed back
thank you Shannon Reed Community College
New Hampshire uh House Bill
716 only makes an appropriation for the
Dual and concurrent enrollment
program which is
presently funded in the governor's House
Bill
one so I think probably um what this is
obviously your decision but what makes
the most sense might be to retain this
bill um and just know that you're
considering the funding
as it's come to you in the governor's
House Bill
one and it's in the governor's House
Bill one at 3 million dollars per
year Rob papovich I will uh incorporate
my previous comments on the previous
bill by reference and not repeat them
but we want to we want to add more money
if we can find any it was cut by the
policy committee because of the budget
tightness
other comments a question Mr chair um I
see the updated fiscal note has reduced
the um expenditures and Appropriations
from 3 million to 2.5 million in fiscal
year 26 and 27 I just wanted to make
sure that that is still the correct
number we're talking about that was the
amendment that we put in in the policy
committee yes okay cut thank you we so
both this bill and the we were just
discussing we flat funded them uh from
the current bayum through to the new
bayum
essentially representative Murray so the
governor's budget had the 3 million in
yes and you put it to two 2.5
million whatever it's at yes I
can yeah well you is that is the two of
us
here unfortunately there were a few
other people involved yes
other
um comments questions represent papich I
just want to point out that uh all the
Motions to do that were pretty much
unanimous and bipartisan so there is
bipartisan support from the policy
committee on this everybody understands
it's tight and again everybody
understands that this is a program that
we really really want to try to find
funding to bring it back to what the
governor asked
for thank you
do I have a motion I have one more quick
question so I'm just looking at um
Mickey's
um um appropriation summary for the last
bill we just discussed and so I guess
Mickey this is my question for you in in
that um note section you you mentioned
that the governor had
recommended um a budget appropriation
but didn't specifically earmark funding
for those that program I'm wondering in
this case is it specifically earmarked
is that how that works because it's its
own sepal Bill and not in the so yes
both of these bills would appropriate
the money specifically for those
programs if you remember when ccsnh came
in earlier this week uh and presented
their Governor's recommended budget all
of these items or excuse me both of
these items the um well actually duel
and concurrent enrollment was somewhat
separate because it was using education
trust funds but the math learning
communities program was just part of
their regular appropriation with no oh
you know statutory or any other
restriction of those funds shall be used
for math learning communities so okay
when we get to ccsnh H's budget in this
committee on house but one and two the
committee can decide if you want to
actually earmark or footnote or you know
say that x amount of dollars for each of
these programs could you remind us when
we get to that discussion um to just re
review that that might be something we
want to discuss we will surely be
discussing that which is why I made the
reference to may still be an
hb2 representative pich you have a
question I'm good okay
other comments
concerns anything else you like to add
no I don't think so thank you so now is
there a
motion happy to make a motion to retain
um HB
716 um yeah so retain
on hb7
16 um as amended by the
house all
right representative papich I
representative Bean yes representative
Dy yes chair wer yes representative
Murray yes representative hackin
Phillips yes representative Earth
yes motion passes
70 thank you madam clerk I will close
the work session
on HB 716 and do we have any other
discussion before I close the work
session Al
together I'm tempted to use the next two
hours to talk but we'll just uh
stop any else you in about three hours I
guess I'll close I'll close the work
session
thank you good to see you
again
e
e e
so since it is 1: p.m. I'd like to call
uh this work session open and we'll
start uh with the EFA discussion at 1:
p.m. you're more than welcome to share
the desk and uh basically this being a
work session we'll be obviously happy to
hear from anything you have to say and
then I'm sure we'll have lots of
questions thank you great I'm Kate Baker
demur I'm the executive director of
children's scholarship fund we
administer our existing education tax
credit scholarship program this is Matt
Southerton our director of policy and
compliance that came along with me
I brought some packets um in the email
it asked us to give an overview of the
ETC program and the EFA program so Matt
will hand out the packets for you that
we brought about the ETC program and we
can start there that's a quick one and
then we brought some packets about the
EFA program and we hope that we have
enough information to answer any
question that you could possibly even
come up with so um we're amicable to to
doing that for sure so the education tax
credit program just quick back ground
was passed by the legislature in
2012 um currently there are um
827 children
participating that's this year for 2425
you'll see that on your top sheet it is
um 2.4 million in scholarships all of
those dollars are raised by human beings
going out and asking people to donate to
the scholarship fund what the
legislature did create was we can offer
a business that donates to us a tax
credit of 85% so a portion of Their
donation against their business
Enterprise and their business profits
tax so page two comes from the
Department of Revenue and that shows you
the amounts of credits that have been
issued by the Department of Revenue over
the course of the program um it seems
like we are stabilizing now if you look
at that top sheet I sent you with all
the pretty colors you'll see kind of our
trajectory from 2016 to now at the
bottom um we're stabilizing in that $2
to3 million range that seems to be what
um we're able to comfortably raise
annually you'll notice we've been in
that2 to3 million range since 2021 2022
and so if you were looking to project
dollars for the ETC it would be safe to
project dollars in that range unless we
add more fundraisers which we don't have
any intention to do
um that's what it will look like
continuously um the way that program
works as well is the legislature wrote
that we could use up to 10% you know
similar to the EFA for administrative
costs um so it doesn't really afford
that many humans um as far as
fundraising employees go but that's what
we would have to do to increase that um
dollar amount I also included in the
package more just for your information a
copy of our annual report which is f
with the Department of Revenue so to do
this work we apply to the Department of
Revenue and we have to meet some
criteria every year once you're an
operating scholarship organization the
criteria is meeting all of the
requirements of the law and so when we
file those annual reports every year we
have to meet all the requirements of the
law and then they'll
reapproved for us that we have been
approved every year to continue to do it
we continue meeting the requirements of
the law working collaboratively with the
Department of Revenue and they haven't
had any concerns or need for concern for
this entire what is it 12 years now I
guess right 2013 was the first year to
now we're in 2025 can you imagine that
I'm going to get some gray soon we're
waiting for
[Laughter]
it so that is the education tax credit
program um as a whole there's been some
debate um or discussion and and we can
go right into the to the EFA program if
you want to and Matt can hand out the
packets for that but yeah yeah maybe
first check if anybody has questions
about the ETC I'm you know yeah while we
are still fresh while it's still fresh
in our minds yeah go ahead okay great
it's interesting with on your colorful
paper um it's a pretty even distribution
across grades there's the bump in second
grade and I guess in third grade and I
was wondering if you just want to speak
to that and the other question is how
many students U repeat how many get
scholarships year after year after year
is this so we've been able to yeah we've
been able to fund every returning child
every year we've been able to raise
enough that's kind of our yard stick
right we don't want to move a child and
tell them they're going to get a
scholarship and then not kind of keep
our word year after year so every year
we've been able to raise enough to fund
the returning kids after we do that then
we open it up to new people and we add
additional students to be able to do
that so that's good what I do notice is
that you know you'll notice at at the
difference between e8th and ninth grade
percentages there are people who exit
the scholarship program to attend their
area high schools as you know in New
Hampshire our local public high schools
are very popular for the sports who want
to do and to be part of your community
and so we do see children exit at 8 to
go to their Area Public High School it
seems like too if you're a if you're a
gifted and talented student when you're
in high school you can choose more
accelerated courses right they they
exist for you but if you're a gifted
second grader you might need a different
school to be able to to get you to to be
able to move at your pace so we notice
things like that overall predominantly
people come to us in the middle of the
year for bullying or they experience
some sort of discrimination they want to
go to a different building um sometimes
people will come more at the beginning
of the year because again they're
looking for a totally different type of
environment you know you have a little
boy who has autism who is struggling in
a traditional classroom and needs to go
to the Montas school right those kinds
of things are are very common reason for
someone to come to us at the beginning
of the year and then also common for
families to exit and go to their
Traditional High School nearby are they
all going to a private school or will
some of this go for homeschooling too
right can see yes so a portion of the
kids are in private school and a portion
of the kids are in in home school so
you'll notice in the stats box you can
see there's a different amount the
legislature said the average scholarship
should should be lower for homeschoolers
than than your regular schoolers and so
there's a there's a portion I'll show
you how it breaks out if you want if you
go to that annual
report there's a list of all the school
scholarships by school here and the
homeschoolers count as one
school so you can see them on where are
they homeschool 108 homeschoolers out of
the total okay so it's usually about 25%
or so of the total student population in
any given year will be homeschoolers and
the constraints around that money is
they can use it for their homeschool
expenses you can't use it for your
parents' time obviously you can't pay
yourself with this and you um can't use
it for athletics and you can't use it
for transportation that's how you guys
wrote that law in 20 12 can you imagine
way back dinosaurs walk in the earth in
2012 about 25% in any given year our our
families that are homeschoolers
yeah we also do see people who don't
want to use the EFA in this program that
are homeschoolers that don't want to use
the EFA because the EFA has so many
constraints they would prefer to use the
money we raise that is private money so
to speak and so there's a group of
homeschoolers like that about 17
families in the ETC program that don't
want to do
EFA but that just um triggered a
followup question are there families who
do both the ETC and EFA yes that's the
beginning of our next conversation yes
so in your you want to hand out the EFA
packets before that a couple of Etc
questions if we may yeah sure we can
I'll go there after no worry one of them
one of them is a very small thing when
you uh printed the report I think
landscape would have been nicer cuz the
zip codes and the accounts of total paid
ended up on a totally separate page fair
and um I was looking at your um amounts
uh if you look at your colorful page on
the bottom right we have fewer awards
for more money in the last year 23 24
that you are reporting on yes the report
that you have is year end right but when
we print it this is the beginnings of
the Year yes so it should reconcile out
by year
ends I'm I'm not sure I understand so
the the the table on the bottom right 1
22 4 you have 1323 people in 2020 to 23
and they didn't pull the so children do
exit yeah that's the difference of
reconciling out the exits when they did
the sheet okay so yeah yeah yeah that's
fine yeah and one very last question you
are saying 50% eligible for the free and
reduced launch on the colored page and
60% in the ed5 is the ed5 for a
different time period than the one that
you printed on EX yes this is the year
we're in the ed5 is last before that I
just wanted to make sure I didn't miss
anything so I'm I'm good on the Etc sees
it anybody else any questions oh go
ahead please GL to see you guys again hi
question on your donors are they mostly
businesses or are they private
individuals that are doing most of the
it's about 90% business 90% because of
the tax credits yes and if you want to
look at who's donating you can go to our
website and we publish our annual report
and they're all listed in there but yes
it is about about 9010 910 awesome thank
you you're welcome cool I think we are
all set if you want to move to the 18
and uh remember to follow up with
representative hackins Philips and who
has the packets to hand out already
passed oh you did okay great so in your
packet skip over the top two pages and
we'll address that question of if you go
to this the moyo family is a great
example so there's two family stories in
here of people that are stacking and I
know there's a lot of debate around
whether we should be able to be allowed
to do that or not that's that's your
decision for sure but I wanted you to
understand how the families are using
those Etc scholarships if they're in the
EFA program so the moyo family is a
family who would otherwise qualify for
free lunch okay so that's their what
that would be 100% of their their 100%
of the poverty line are below but they
have two children who attend private
schools and the private school tuitions
are 7500 and
6,500 their EFA even with the free and
reduced lunch differentiated Aid is
$5,600
and so we would give that type of family
a small scholarship remember the ETC
scholarship average is only like drra
says that can be a maximum of
$3,000 all put together so those
scholarships are usually around
$2500 we would give a family like the
Moos a scholarship to make up that Gap
so that they wouldn't be in a position
where they had their EFA and then they
couldn't you know they couldn't come up
with the per month tuition bills to make
up that Gap and there's two families in
here just like that for you to to see
what that looks like and if I may
quickly interject I'm assuming that
situations like this are based on the
income level of the family and
demonstrated need this wouldn't this
type of stuff wouldn't be available to
somebody who could easily afford the the
private tuition if they wanted to well
currently for example the ETC program
has lower income limits than the EFA so
we would number one be constrained by
that and then number two be con trained
also by the targeting of the ETC so
those the reports and what the
Department of Revenue is checking in the
ETC is as you've notice the number of
free and reduced lunch children has to
be above 40% in that program and the
program is also targeted to you designed
it targeted to switchers meaning a kid
coming from public school moving to
private school so if you're a low-income
family and you're coming from a public
school you're going to end up in that
number one bucket in the ETC you've also
noticed that the fund raising in the ETC
is around 2 or three million a year and
so since we run out of money every year
we have to prioritize the families that
are going to meet the help us right to
file that report and meet the
requirements of the law which are
low-income kids that are moving from
public school and so the Moos coming to
us as a low-income family would be in
that top bucket to be able to get a
scholarship if you were above the income
limits for the ETC you would
automatically not get a scholarship and
then in addition we wouldn't be
prioritizing you to get the scholarship
money I mean the donors donating want to
be able to help families exactly like
this to be able to bridge those gaps so
it's donor intent and it's also the
constraints you guys designed that
program really well thank
you so now we're on the EFA discussion
and I thought that it made the most
sense to kind of give you an overview of
this like I gave you an overview of the
ETC program you know this one was a law
passed in 2021 and it was the families
in the pandemic that really drove this
into being when the schools were closed
and they were trying to get tutors and
technology and whatnot to be able to
meet their needs in that time period
many families moved to um private
schools that were open or started their
own homeschool co-ops during the
pandemic to try and meet their
children's needs those were the families
that were demanding really that that
something like this be passed and so
that that's why it exists and you'll see
a lot of that as we go through this
discussion the income limits on this
program are slightly higher than the ETC
this is
350% of poverty line or below the
eligibility is also different than the
Etc in that this one says you have to be
a child who's otherwise eligible to
enroll in your primary or secondary
school which just so you know means
you're 5 years old by September 30th
that's when you could enroll in
kindergarten or you're you haven't
graduated yet and you're up to the age
of 21 is it Matt and 22 now if you have
a special needs so if you have an IEP
your special needs child you can stay in
school or in the EFA program until
you're 22 and then you would Age out so
that's what it looks like you can't use
an EFA if you're full-time in your
District public school or full-time in a
charter school and all of you know
already that this is the child's
adequate education grant traveling from
the education trust fund so it couldn't
go in two places It could only go in one
place to that end though they you did
design in this law um the stabilization
grants or what do they call them the
grant that goes to the public school
anyway if the child leaves and that goes
I think until 2026 so you are in fact
paying for them twice in this and those
um grants that you give for a certain
period of time and then after you know a
certain number of years then you pay for
them once in the money following the
child into the EFA so this is the same
money could go to a public school if
they were there could go to a charter
school if they were there can go to the
EFA if they're there if they move to a
different town for example if you move
from Manchester to Bedford this money
would go from Manchester to
Bedford um yeah by all means I'm happy
to take you're asking you mentioned the
age limit aging out at um who's using
this once Beyond High School um no one
you have once you've graduated yes once
you've graduated you're out of this Thea
do we actually have a lot of students
who are 21 years old and still in high
school special education only special
education only kids with IEPs yes we do
have one student who is aging out of the
program this year who is an IEP who has
an IEP yes and funds are swept as soon
as a student graduates yeah so that's
the end in some states they've made it
so the funds go into like coverdell or
college accounts but when you guys were
discussing this nobody thought that was
a good idea everybody thought just put
it back in the education trust fund we
need the money right so there you go
yeah so that's how that is so because
the income limits are 350% of poverty
line or below every family is applying
with their um tax return or their
financial documentation so if you have a
1040 and you use a a 1040 you know your
regular tax return that's what you give
us to prove your residency your
household size and your adjusted gross
income to be able to qualify for the
program if you're a family who um is a
low-income family who might be um sub
you know subsiding on on tanif and snap
then your TANF and snap documents are
sufficient to qualify you you know that
a family that gets food stamps qualifies
for SNAP also qualifies for free and
reduced lunch um that's the piece that
families reapply for every year so while
we might let them in at the first gate
with their tax return they've qualified
in the next year they continue giving us
their financial information if they want
to continue qualifying for free and
reduced lunch okay because you have to
qualify for that annually if you don't
want to qualify for that money you can
just reapply by proving your residency
and then providing us with remember each
of these families has to provide us with
a record of educational attainment it's
called they have to do a standardized
test either the Statewide assessment or
uh standardized test that's nationally
normed like you'll think of the Iowa or
the cat or the I ready or have their
portfolio evaluated by a teacher at a
non-public school or a certified teacher
and so when you're requalifying in that
second year if you don't want to apply
for the special ed differentiated Aid
where you would need an IEP or a
diagnosis from a qualified professional
and you don't want to apply for free and
reduced lunch then you could do the
record of educational attainment and The
Residency qualification and stay in the
program when we're doing that
application process if you want to hang
on for a second I can answer questions
absolutely I like it I prefer
interactive just so you
know oh well thank you go ahead um
around the accountability um can you
speak more directly about um especially
you know pertaining to homeschoolers
because who's there to do the
accountability and so you're talking
about academic accountability how do you
know these kids are actually learning
anything sure and the second thing is
what happens if they do not reach that
attainment what do you do with that
family that child yeah do you want to
pull out the list of the what their
families are doing so I don't have that
list oh you don't okay hold on I do yeah
so we are required by law I get it put
my back go ahead start you talk okay so
so we're required by law to uh produce
aggregated scores for the Department of
Education we
don't make value judgments on what the
parents do with those scores however we
believe that's just have one copy but
you could pass
it what Kate's giving Mickey right now
is a breakdown of the different methods
that the parents use to assess their
student scores um oh he's going to make
a copy awesome yeah so in essence the
way we look at this representative
Murray is the parent is the driver in
this program so they're the ones that
are deciding I'm going to home school
this year I'm going to go to a private
school next year I'm going to go to a
charter school the year after that I'm
going to I'm going to go to a public
school the year after that I'm going to
go back to a private school the year
after that and they're using the test
scores to inform their decisions and the
information from the teacher to inform
their decisions and so the role that we
play in this is the compliance piece
where we're making sure they're meeting
the requirements of the law which is to
take the test and prove to us that
they've done it or to get their
portfolio evaluated by the teacher and
show us that they've done it I haven't
seen a portfolio evaluation letter that
tells me the child has not made growth
that's appropriate for their grade or
have I seen a score that caused me any
kind of alarm as a matter of fact
remember most of these kids in in the
program are participating in a private
school and the test scores in our
private schools look like Bedford you
know those kids are scoring 85th
percentile or above like Hanover or
Bedford so the scores look like that
they look like what we know about these
kids that they're in our private schools
in New Hampshire and the private schools
score high that they you know the SAT
scores are high the portfolio evaluation
say it's appropriate for the grade
otherwise again we're directing the
parent to use this information to make
educated decisions about the pathways
that they determine for their child I
have heard from parents that said I feel
like my child was needs to be better at
reading I'm going to use the EFA to get
a reading tutor so my child can improve
in this area and so it really is a a
holistic review for the parent so that
they can make the educational decisions
our role is to make sure they're doing
what they're required to do by law
collect that data and you know provide
it to you like this if I may briefly
build on the same question I'm looking
at this handout that we just got and it
it seems to be roughly 50 50/50 between
parents who use standardized tests and
parents who use portfolios of work
obviously standardized tests are
standardized so it's easy to evaluate
there can you maybe tell us a little bit
more you know you look at portfolios of
work you know just in Broad terms how do
you measure progress on a portfolio of
work in general you have to be a teacher
a certified teacher or a teacher in a in
a non-public school to judge that and
I'm neither of those things and so I I
would just tell you that I've read them
and I know they say this child has shown
growth that's appropriate for their age
I couldn't tell you what a teacher would
look at I would assume again that a
teacher would look at if they're telling
me the child is making growth commerate
with their ability and their age that
they're looking at approximately to be
grade level appropriate items I also
know that we are tracking the children
by grade we're saying this child's in
kindergarten then first then second then
third I sometimes will see the families
using a test score for a higher grade
you know they'll say well my child is is
in third grade but they're doing fifth
grade work so I'm fifth grade cat
testing them and so I do see that happen
where the teacher or the family seems to
apply to the student the appropriate
academic work for their developmental
level instead of their aged grade level
and I think that makes good sense to me
but basically the evaluation is made by
somebody who is you know teaching the
kid you guys just review that it exists
and look at them overall to see if are
any flags of concern you are not
equipped nor required to individually
assess every kid or any of it really is
a compliance activity yes and in terms
of compliance you you put a mechanism in
the law where if they don't provide us
with that data we are supposed to report
to the Department of Education on August
1 any students that did not comply with
that and we are prohibited from putting
any additional funds into the EFA
account yeah so we're just we're the
compliance monitors we're the hall
monitors over here you know the police
making sure you're not speeding a very
popular position please proceed
representative M thank you good question
yeah good question good question so we
were talking about the application were
was there a question you had about our
application
processing because that's what I covered
I don't want to move on if anyone has
any questions about how we process
applications oh I was going to go on to
talk about the state database and how uh
we assign the children assass some
people say to me how do you know that a
child is not in their Public School and
in the EFA at the same time right and we
do have a Statewide student information
system which you might already know
about um it is currently called
i4c and they're moving to a new um
platform called idex but in that every
student in New Hampshire who
participates in an EFA looks like a
public school student they get one of
those State identifiers and we can cross
reference this data with the data of the
children that are sitting in the seats
of course not with any information right
just by number so that it's it looks
Anonymous until you try and go search
for so we can cross reference our data
and we do this um four times a year with
the data of the children in the seats in
the public schools and the charter
schools so that we can find any what the
dep Department of Ed calls anomalies and
then reconcile those anomalies so that
we know that a family is in the EFA Who
belongs in the EFA if they transfer back
to public school right they're exiting
the EFA and we have to all get our dates
right if they exit the FAA on October
31st and they go to public school on
November 1 right we'd have to make sure
we exit them on that date and Etc so
it's a constant back and forth between
us and the department of Ed and of
course all the public schools in the
state and Charter Schools already do
this making sure that all of the
students are in the right I don't want
to call them buckets because kind of
mean for kids but buildings so to speak
even though our program isn't a building
yeah can you correct me I've got
something bug in my brain that there was
some certain conditions
where I I want to say the EFA students
and I'm wondering if I'm conflating it
with home students who aren't efas
although I don't know if any of those
even exist but they do make use of a
public school for some services and so
to great question there are EFA students
in public school which is an anomaly and
can you address you know what happened
you can use your EFA to pay for Public
School tuition at a district that's not
your own okay and people have been doing
that in New Hampshire all over the place
I don't know if you know how much that
actually happens where you'll be in a
town and the next town over they have a
stem program that you want to attend and
you call the school and you say hey I
want my child to attend your District
school instead of mine what would you
charge me and the school says we're
going to charge you X for example
there's a school in gilsum called gilsum
steam where kids are tuition in from all
over the place and parents are paying
and I think it's only $6,000 a year so
you can use your EFA to pay an out of
District Public School
you also can go to your local district
and ask if you can participate in
classes and courses you can't be
full-time public school and full-time
EFA but you can be an EFA student and
then go back to your public school and
purchase a class or course with your EFA
dollars that's one of the allowable
categories for example I watch some
teenagers go to their local public high
schools and pay for the AP classes so
some of the classes they were doing at
the community college some classes they
were doing online some classes they were
doing at their local public high school
they wanted those AP classes they had so
they were paying them a little bit of
tuition and the district just came up
with the dollar amount that the family
should pay and they were using the EFA
to pay for those classes and courses so
it's been really cool to watch kids
choose different we call them education
providers now instead of talking about
schools choose different education
providers for different types of
educational needs and then create the
really creative programs because I think
that just sounds like a blast wish that
existed when I was a kid right yeah I
think it's also uh good to highlight the
fact that public schools are flexible
and accommodate these kids and try to
find the solution that works for
everybody I think that deserves a lot of
recognition too yeah and that kids love
it I mean you might want to so I've
watched kids go to the public schools
for the more accelerated you know math
and science type classes maybe in that
family the parent thought that's out of
my le and so I want them to go for that
you also watch a lot of little
elementary school kids who will go to
their um local public school for art and
music which just sounds like a great
time to me right going over and having
art class and enjoying your peers and so
yes it is it's it's a very nice
arrangement that the fact that you made
that a category allowable under the law
makes a lot of sense to me can you
explain something you I perhaps I
misheard I thought I heard you say you
cannot be a full-time public school
student and have full-time EFA that's
right you have unless you're out of
District okay yes is there such a thing
as a part-time EFA no you would be the
EFA student would be going and taking a
class or two at their local District
okay so you'd be full-time EFA but you'd
be using your EFA money to buy classes
and courses from your local District if
you were participating there okay yeah
you got it yep you got it so I talked
about the
SDS so we look like the EFA program if
you look at it looks like it just looks
like a giant District in the way we do
all of our reporting so once we assign
that SD the child becomes eligible for
the EFA and then we're giving the
department of Ed six reports a year a
beginning of the year report in October
which is one of those reconciliation
reports like I talked about an endof
thee report which is when we do our end
of the year reconciliation and you'll
see the the um exits and graduating kids
when we get to our audit I can point
that out to you um and then we do four
times a year enrollment reports so we
look just like a district getting an
installment of adequate education grants
September 1 November 1 January and April
and before each of those we give the
report to the Department of Ed I say
give we're using the Statewide database
information system and putting the
report in the system we're doing that 30
days before each of those payments and
the family's deadline is two weeks
before that when they have to have a
completed application to get in okay so
that's what it looks like those
installments so which is why when I was
discussing earlier a child coming in and
going out right you might come in then
you'll exit you won't be in the next
enrollment report the charter schools
look similar the EFA and the charter
schools are all paid in real time I
don't know if you know but your
districts are paid a year and a re we're
not like that we're our stuff is all in
real
time and now I'm going to go um so after
we get that uh so say we're at September
1 the department of Ed has received our
report they've calculated the grant
amounts given it back to us we take that
award and we put it in a digital wallet
the platform is called class wallet you
might have heard that word bounced
around what class wallet is is a
platform that we log into that the
families can log into on their end and
their child's Grant amount sits in the
digital wallet um we use that so that we
can again remember the B the bad cops
here so that we can regulate it to be
sure that the families are meeting the
requirements of the law so they can't do
anything with it everything comes to us
that they do something it comes to us we
approve it I'm just going to stop
talking and go to Matt because he's much
better at explaining this so Matt so I
am the the nerdy rules guy here so the
role of the compliance team to assure is
to ensure that EFA funds are are spent
properly right so we have seven seven
members of the of the compliance team
team uh old members are trained and they
receive training in the following
resources that the the EFA law
administrative rules the the state
contract program policies parent
handbook and the class wallet platform
uh to date we've processed over 169,000
orders
153,000 orders have been approved
16,41 orders have been rejected so we
have about a 10.6% error rate or not
error rate pardon me uh rejection rate
all class wallet orders are held in an
order approval Quee until the order is
reviewed an order may be approved denied
placed on incomplete or on hold will we
request more information so can I take a
sidebar because I'm seeing a little
confusion on everyone's face so if your
child is attending private school and
you want to pay your private school you
create an order in class wallet that has
your bill that you want to pay to the
private school so I'm parent I'm Mary
and my children go to where the Moos go
St Joe's in Manchester and I want to pay
for Sally my child at St Joe's I go to
St Joe's and I say I want to pay you
with my EFA they give me my bill that I
owe them I bring it to my class Wallet
account I go to Mary's account I log
into as you know I go to my child's
account when I'm in my child's EFA
digital wallet I'm saying I want to pay
St Joe's you can pick it from a list and
put it in the order and I want to pay
them $2,000 because that's all I have
because I only have my first installment
here but my you know my bill is 6,000 I
put my bill in there showing that I want
to pay them this amount and then it goes
to Matt not Matt but the compliance team
they're going to look at it so that
that's how this order he's saying is
created it's created by the parent who's
saying I want to do x with this money
and essentially there are three methods
of using EFA funds in class wallet
there's the marketplace order which is
an online Marketplace of approved EA
vendors there's a direct pay order where
a where a parent can essentially upload
an invoice of EFA approved vendors and
then there's the re reimbursement
mechanism that you all put into the law
and all EFA in order to submit a
reimbursement order the the vendor needs
to be EFA approved as well
um that process actually takes more time
than direct pay or Marketplace orders uh
but I would say that we manage it pretty
well yeah and the the marketplace order
so you understand what that looks like
it's stores that are that are in this
closed loop so everything in this class
wallet platform is like a closed loop
you can't get anything in or out without
without using the the class wallet tools
and so you can go into your child's
remember I'm s Mary I've Sally's my
child I'm in Sally's account and I want
to get uh paper okay I can go to Staples
while I'm in there I can say while I'm
at the staple store store I want to buy
these three notebooks and this box of
pencils then it's in a cart then the
cart goes to the team and the team's
looking at the cart to say is this
allowable or unallowable under the law
is it for the particular child for
example if you were in there and you
went to you can go to Amazon that's why
you'll notice when everyone's always
talking about the expenses there's like
there's so much at Amazon it's built
into the system if you went to Amazon
and you bought a math textbook for Sally
say we're going I'm going to tell you
s's in second grade okay and Sally's
brother's in sixth grade okay just so
you know and I'm Mary and I went in
there and I by mistake was in the sixth
graders thing and I should have been in
the second graders thing I put the sixth
graders textbook in the cart for Sally
but Sally's in second grade that would
get rejected right because you would say
okay this textbook isn't for Sally
because Sally should be in second grade
they do have a notes box yes there's
quite a few kids who are above and below
the grade levels in this program that's
why they're here right because they they
don't f in the Box they need to do
something different but the parent could
say Sally is a gifted reader so I'm
buying her this fifth grade textbook
because that's her level that she's
working at in Reading then we would say
okay if it was blank we would say not
okay because parent you have to tell us
that the sixth grade textbook actually
is for Sally or the parent says we
rejected and they say oops you're right
I was in the wrong kids bucket and I
should have toggled to the other child
to put this the grade book second grade
book in the other child and so when Matt
says we've done 169,000 of these things
boy oh boy let me tell you and and each
method has an individual checklist per
method on what metrics what individual
requirements are for that so for example
um every direct pay order every every
reimbursement order requires certain
fields on that receipt they have to be
itemized we need the we need the date we
need the vendor name we need the student
name first name last name we need for if
if it was a direct pay order for an
invoice due we need that amount due on
there uh if it's a reimbursement we need
the exact date that it was paid how much
it was paid uh so that's again that's
why we have about a 10.6% rejection rate
because a an order can be rejected for
any number of reasons there could be
there could be an error on the receipt
there could be missing information the
item could not be allowable we have a in
if you look in the parent handbook we
have a list of prohibited items on there
household items you know you can't buy
paper towels you can't buy
uh you know lawn mower so we you know a
lot of people criticize the program for
that but we have a detailed prohibited
items list and category come on even if
I'm trying to teach my kid mechanics no
I'm kid sorry um quick question though
you can definitely get a mechanics book
A book on mechanics or your student can
you're enroll in a CTE yeah my um when
we talked about special education
earlier we learned about the Department
of Education vetting those expenses but
obviously they were only looking at the
nature of the expense not the amount
based on everything you say that's what
you guys do too right you not the judges
of whether the price is reasonable
you're just looking to see that it is an
allowable educational expense it's
qualif but you cannot go beyond that you
just you cannot say oh my God why are
you paying 10,000 tuition when it could
be 2,000 we absolutely cannot make value
judgments correct I appreciate I just
want you to make sure that we are kind
of on the same footing between those
because
frankly you know I'm more worried about
the special education but it's good to
understand how the entire system works
in terms of those rules yeah absolutely
can you talk a little bit about the
appeals process now because I think they
might understand now how the appeal how
a parent could appeal our decision if so
we are required by law to have an
appeals process we have a two-step
appeals process we have an internal
appeals process and an external appeals
process to the uh parent and education
service provider oversight commission
the internal appeals process step one if
the parent decides that you know they
don't agree with our ision whether it's
uh student eligibility for the program
or an expense they don't believe you
know we they don't they believe that
that expense is eligible they can impal
internally using that process outlined
in our policy and our parent handbook uh
you know they email us they provide
documentation why they believe that this
is an educational expense we review that
appeal we make our determination we
adjudicate that appeal yes or no if they
still if we if we determine it's not an
eligible expense they can uh escalate
that that to the parent and provider uh
ad oversight yeah advisory commission
and then to date we've only had two
folks you know two families use that
appeal process uh that that provider
commission they decided that you know we
made the right decision and they deny
those both of those appeals because what
we do try to do is give people
Alternatives we provide process right if
and and if somebody wants to do
something so you're talking about
mechanics right if you want to do
something we might tell you you can't
buy all the tools that you would need to
do that but here's some programs you
could sign up for where you could have
the same experience and it could be
allowable right so we do tend to again
we are you know I want to just remind
you how we get paid in this okay
remember that you're sending these
adequate education grants to us for the
families and we are paid from that money
okay so you'll see when we get to the
audit discussion that our admin fee was
7.97 and so that's coming from the
parent the parent is in fact paying us
to do this work from their child's
adequate education grant and so we do
work for them and see it see it that way
and want to provide them with the level
of service that they need to be able to
make good decisions for their child and
help them navigate this world you might
come to us and it's the first time
you've been in the driver's seat as a
parent it's the first time you're
thinking about I could could be doing
all of these different types of using
all these different types of Education
providers one of our staff members um
has been who's great at customer service
has been promoted at this point her
title is education opportunity Navigator
and she sets up appointments with
parents who are trying to figure out
what kinds of things work for their
child and will'll take hours talking to
them about this mapping right
educationally mapping the pathways for
their children so yes we are rejecting
10% of the orders but when we do reject
we try and tell the family the thing
that they could do that's close to what
they're trying to accomplish to help
them Reach those goals with their child
right and it could be rejected just
because there's in a date on the receipt
sure I think the lawnmower example
question if you don't mind that's the
hardest thing for me to sell to my
constituents when I talk to them about
this is they feel like parents are using
the money and it's not being approved
properly so I'm happy to hear that you
have such great that I'm the bad cops
you're that that you are such bad cops
because I think a lot of them want to
use it but their neighbors are bullying
and and saying oh you're going to spend
money on things that shouldn't be spent
on so thank you thank you so the the
lawn mower example is a great example
and the reason a lawn mower wouldn't be
approved is because you know we view EFA
accounts as as awarded on an individual
per pupil basis and something like a
lawn mower or a large screen TV is not
for for the child right it could be used
by the the full family so that's that's
how we would view this a student can buy
an individual you know a laptop computer
for them to do their education uh the
administrative rules say you can you can
purchase one every three years right and
we log those computers we literally they
say when can we purchase a new computer
for my child and I'll look it up and
I'll say you know six more months you
can buy that computer but you can't do
household items because it's not for the
child right you know I can't buy a a
what is the the the big mixer oh yeah
for example kitchen mixer do a cooking
lesson for your child for science right
we wouldn't pay for your KitchenAid
mixer right because that's a household
item we also wouldn't pay for the food
right because we don't allow food okay
but you could get the book that you were
going to follow for that class you
couldn't buy your kitchen tools because
those are household items just you can't
buy furniture for example right you
couldn't buy a desk for your child
because think about it a desk is just
like a couch right a desk isn't an
educational item I'm sitting at a desk
right now but it's not necessary I could
be sitting in that chair and have the
same exact experience as sitting at the
desk so it's not an educational item for
the child and the parents do struggle
with that and yes sometimes they get mad
at us when they have some Vision in
their mind and we say you can't get a
desk and they're like why can't I get a
desk is a perfect example right of
something you would think we might be
able to allow but it really is furniture
for your house and that people are
getting upset at the people they talk to
but your hands are tied by the language
in the statute so uh it may not be a bad
idea to remind them that we are the ones
that create those R there are 400 of us
to take the angry that's not the best
customer service though representative
we try and help them solve the challenge
that they're trying to solve of course I
was just talking about dealing with a an
inappropriate blaming towards the group
give them your number I do I do know
that you're I do know that your time is
precious I do want to add one more cave
yet cuz I'm the nerdy rules guy I am
working with a mother whose child has
cbop po
and they do require an accommodation so
they are you know they do use um
cushions sort of things it's not really
a couch but we will make accommodations
for them if they have proper
documentation for those required by
their special ed correct specific
specialed provider who says they
absolutely must have this and they have
the IEP to back it up you're right yeah
fair enough yeah so it is already at 145
so I would I'm sorry yeah and just
before before go there look of course we
want to stick to the schedule but it's
also important to cover everything that
needs to be covered so don't worry about
it we'll try not to waste time and use
every moment go ahead and present thank
you can you speak to some of the issues
where it seems like things have slipped
through the cracks and they have been
inappropriately you know funds um
there's the article and I you're quoted
in here all the time about the conquered
monitor um kids going to uh music camp
in Michigan for instance right um those
kinds of things where there's been an
appropriation which seems to be totally
inappropriate um students that are
taking courses outside of New Hampshire
can you speak to you know um how that's
happened uh what you do about that um I
do not want to use the word fraud
because I tend to think High more highly
of people than that great but um I think
it's very clear that there have been
misuses of funds and if you can kind of
address how you do that you know can you
explain um how you support sending a
child to music camp in
absolutely so the law has a list of can
you pull up the core knowledge subjects
to read Matt you think you have that
computer okay hold on let me do that
first so in there's a list of subjects
the families have to cover okay and in
that list of subjects art and music are
in there and so is PE okay if you're a
home educated child to meet those
requirements in the law you likely don't
have access to PE class like you would
think traditionally in a school or a a
music class you have to choose classes
and courses that meet those requirements
that are otherwise you know the same
type of thing for example you're seeing
families doing ski programs those are
homeschool families using the ski
program to meet their physical education
requirement and so the policy decision
that you guys can make is whether or not
you think that's a appropriate it it is
allowable so it wouldn't be fraud or an
in inappropriate use based on the
existing law because the law has this
list of subjects that the families when
they sign into to the program they say
we agree to do all of these things and
so music and PE are both required
subjects in the law and families that
are outside of buildings are choosing
multiple different types of Education
providers to meet that requirement um it
doesn't have to be something in New
Hampshire either so I'll give you an
example of how we approve private
schools so you've got these you know
take the border of Vermont and Maine and
the people that live on those borders
right you probably know about our um
interstate compacts that we have even in
the public schools where a kid might
travel across the border to go to school
every day if they live in New Hampshire
they go to Vermont and they come back
for those instances we look to see is
the private school approved by the State
Department of Education in the state
that the private school is located in so
for example if you wanted to take a
class at a private school in Vermont as
long as that school is approved by the
department of Ed in Vermont then we can
add them as an as an approved education
provider and so what that means is that
music program that that child went to
wrote to us and signed up to be an
approved EFA provider we vetted them to
make sure that they qualify they agreed
to all of the terms and condition they
got into that class Wallet account so
the families could use it to pay it and
the family used it again to meet that
music requirement which in fact they
they've agreed to do when they signed up
for the program just to quickly build on
that uh you brought up a you know
Michigan Music
Camp I would assume that the family was
responsible for the travel and the
whatever abely only CA that you guys
reimbursed was the actual tuition or
Camp CA or whatever the AC those
categories that are allowable in the law
so for example you couldn't do any room
and board there's no category for a room
and board expense you could do tuition
at something and so yes and I would note
that the ETC prohibits Athletics by the
way so I mean you could Etc does but not
the EFA but you could have done that if
you wanted to in your program design
yeah go ahead she did of course welcome
great question too thank you for the
good question hi yeah no worry we are
aware we appreciate you being
here trust me if you ask something
that's already on tape we'll let you
know so I'm wondering if you want to go
to oh hang on for a moment let's
accommodate uh representative Kelly go
ahead okay hi representative Kelly
welcome to the party hi thank you I've
been waiting for this party and then I
had to miss some of it I'm sorry we had
County that we were doing this morning
so um so you've already gone through how
the Wallet account Works um I might go
back to that and I'm sorry but I I do
understand that the money in the EFA um
account is non-aps and can roll over to
the next year is there a limit to the
number of years that that rollover can
happen it's swept once the student
graduates or leaves the EA so
potentially you could have a 10e or 12E
rollover
could yeah I people use it but yes you
conceivably hypothetically yeah
hypothetically yeah um until I I
understand that this is until age 18 or
um graduation' got um yeah some people
do I notice some people do save for High
School tuition I've seen a couple of
families so if if people don't use their
accounts we call them because we wonder
if they're just lost people right so if
somebody isn't logged into their class
wallet account and tried to pay some
tuition or tutor or something we call
them to find out you know do you need
help because remember they're using
pretty advanced technology here to have
to use the money and there have been a
couple of families who said I'm going to
send my child to private high school X
private high school X costs this much
and I am saving for that child to go to
this you know expensive private high
school okay so at the I'm going to step
back to uh okay so 18 happens they
graduate there's money left in the
account yeah so how does that um get
returned to the state great so we'll
take a sidebar do you have one of these
packets did you give okay great so head
over to our audit which is is towards
the end
okay we do an annual reconciliation so
the thing you missed representative
Kelly is the six reports that we do for
the Department of Ed every year we do
four aois which are enrollment reports
we do at the beginning of the year and
end of the year report and in our end of
the year report is a
Reconciliation so if you go all the way
to the audit you 16 for the record yes
exactly it says note J okay you can see
that line right there less funds due to
State of New Hampshire that's our
year-end reconciliation where any of the
children that have exited or graduated
we return those we sweep the money from
their class Wallet account and return it
to the state and we do that by Child by
payment and I can tell you it's very
large book Mickey would like it
spreadsheet I'm very surprised it adds
up to a million I would have thought
parents would it's also cumulative
you'll remember right of course of
course but still yes you know it's um
anyway decisions I'm not going to
complain about getting money back that
parents didn't use so yes that's right
and it goes back into the education
trust fund the law says actually to fund
other EFA accounts just so you know yeah
yeah so I make sure I misunderstood so
is it conceivable that a person you know
in first grader not you know a family
with a first grader could apply for an
EFA yeah and not use it it's hypothetic
grade fourth grade fifth grade seventh
grade until they get to ninth grade so
they're just taking this money and using
it basically as a personal savings
account it it is they are called
education savings accounts that is the
policy design the EFA we're talking
about the yes yes go grade yes it's very
unusual they could to your point
representative Kelly they could get the
EFA dollars leave them in the class
Wallet account graduate and we would
give them all back right so it's I mean
conceivably yes you could become part of
the EFA program and not use it and then
graduate and we would put it all back
that doesn't happen the families are
spending the money to your point as you
saw in the conquered monitor article
right the families are definitely
spending the money so what if a student
is Cruise all that money y it's uh April
May of their senior year they haven't
quite graduated yet and they're still
not of age yet yeah they have all this
money acred over that whole period of
time because it's rolled over and
they've already been admitted into a
college can they use that money on a
college
tuition that's a good question I don't
know I'd have to ask Matt to answer that
because he does all that work from
that excuse me from what I'm reading in
the parent handbook yeah they can use it
for dual enrollment they can't they
can't pay tuition ahead of time you're
what prevents
that they would they could they could
submit an invoice if they were in 12th
grade yeah and they could take college
classes they can't submit an invoice for
next year for their first year of
college oh of performance yeah we
wouldn't we would we wouldn't I just
want to make sure 10 was being said if I
may so what you are saying is that the
time when we disburse the funds the time
period in which we disburs the funds has
to match the time period in which the
educational expense is applied to so if
a college sends me an advance bill for
next fall because I graduate in July or
whatever in June nothing past June where
the actual work would occur past June
could be paid ahead of time I I don't
want to put words in your mouth but
that's what I think I hear you say I
think that's what representative K this
hypothetical I don't think we've seen
that to actually be able to adjudicate
it which is why we're both kind of like
huh we we haven't had to adjudicate
anything like that so we haven't seen
that and so it's a it's a hypothetical
that is a new idea to us if you if
you're wondering why we're kind of like
okay well I I I mean it's an excellent
question out there that my understanding
from some of these parents is that
they've been told they can acrew this
money over a long period of time and at
the end because the child has not
actually graduated they could pay ahead
they could pay ahead to Performance they
wouldn't be able to do that so we'll
write that in the parent handb represent
Kelly so you've helped us today thank
you very much not use this for college I
would not be surprised if people
misunderstand the rules and offer better
advice but I think anybody trying to
take that advice will be sorely
disappointed and we also have missed on
a lot of educational opportunities and
just return the money to the state it's
clearly articulated that this is cas
through 12 funding yeah so thank you for
that you have a list of uh qualified
College yes and articulated in the law
in the yeah it's articulated in the law
that it's K to 12 yeah but kids do while
they haven't graduated take dual
enrollment classes quite frequently
there's quite a few kids who will take a
class at the community college but
they're doing that to meet their High
School graduation requirements we just
talked this morning about the ccsnh
yeah but some some of those are college
credits so it is college when you're in
high school and you haven't graduated
and you take a college class like
English composition it will count for
high school credit and college credit
but we don't hold that against them if
they also need it for high school credit
so that I mean that's normal any high
schooler in New Hampshire can
participate in those programs yeah so
you did make it allowable in the law to
use it in that way when you're a k to2
student but we hadn't actually ever
pondered what you were discussing and so
I think it's reasonable to put that in
the parent handbook and just say oh yeah
you couldn't use this to pay for your
traditional right if you're going to pay
for your next school year and you're
graduating that doesn't make sense
you're right no more than you could pay
for you know no more than you could pay
in advance for you know seventh grade in
private school if you're in sixth grade
and you have money left over you know
you couldn't pay for seventh grade
because that's next year so yeah you
know of course because you are still
enrolled you could just wait until
seventh grade starts but you couldn't
pay while you are still in sixth grade
so yes yes
and I guess my main point is to your
question representative Kelly there
aren't people acre money like that and
so I think that's why we're having a
little bit of difficulty answering your
question because families are spending
the money fairly expeditiously they're
only getting small amounts so if you
imagine if you have just the Base
adquate education Grant and you don't
have sped special ed and you don't have
free and reduced lunch you have less
than $4,000 divided into four payments
September November January and April and
they go 20% 20% 30% 30% but let's just
for all intents and purposes imagine
that it's just even right you would get
$1,000 in September a th000 in November
right you and so that's not very much
money
to save I guess if I if it makes sense
particularly since most of these
families remember they're like 50% free
and reduced lunch families I mean
they're spending the money basically so
well it's unusual question would say
that the the program hasn't been in
place long enough for you to know what's
happening at the end perhaps yes thank
you for that advice so on page 15 of
your parent handbook there's the very
last paragraph it says enrolling as a
full-time student in the Resident
District Public School are not
submitting an annual record of
educational attainment by July 15th
shall result in immediate suspension of
payment of additional funds into the
students EFA so the student is no longer
in the EFA program for various reasons
it does say though however an EFA that
has been open for at least one full
school year shall remain open and active
for the parent to make qualifying
educational expenses from the remaining
funds the funds remaining in the EFA so
how is it that that works if the student
is no longer yeah in EFA but the account
is open so they can continue even though
they're going back to public school they
can continue to withdraw from the EFA
account yeah that's that's how the law
was written if a students in the has
been in the EFA for a year or longer
they're they're able to retain those
funds if there are any funds left over
yeah sounds like so you keep the money
that
you're entitled to so to speak right so
say for example you're there September 1
and you get that September 1 installment
and then you go back to public school
before the next installment in November
one so so October 30th you withdraw and
you have $15 left in your account
remember that was money that you were
entitled to September one you were
eligible for those funds so that's why
the legislature said you could spend
that remaining
$15 it could be a lot more than 15 maybe
you would use it to put by two I have
seen a family use it to pay for tutoring
in addition to their public school for a
few sessions when they went back yeah
but again remember they're eligible for
that installment and so that's why the
legislature said you're eligible for it
you can use it didn't you say earlier
though that money that um with you know
someone is leaves the EFA program that
the money is swept back to the
Department of Education I graduate yeah
so it's both and they if it's less than
a year Okay so if you look at our
withdrawal form it says exactly what
representative Kelly is saying or you
can choose I want to Forfeit and send it
back to the state so it's either or if
you've been in the program for more than
a year you have the opportunity to say I
want to do X if you haven't you withdraw
and it's swept so it's both and does
representative Dy had a question that
may help or not but it has to be a
qualified expense of course you're still
constrained by the law AB for qualified
so they can't take it and and do
something
without it being a right so let me see
if I can summarize because I want to
make sure I'm still on board with
everything that's being asked the
concern is that we're trying to
understand what happens when students
are no longer eligible they left the
program for whatever reason right and my
understanding of what I've heard through
now is that if they've been there for
less than a year or if they exit because
they graduate then they have no choice
the money just gets bounced straight
back to the state if they remain if they
have been in the program for at least a
year and theoretically they could be
eligible to rejoin back because they're
going to public school but maybe next
year they'll come back then we don't
sweep the funds they remain in their
account and they can still use them for
educational expenses there is only one
thing that I did not catch that I would
like to know which is say that we've
been getting the first quarterly payment
you know would those expenses that are
eligible are only eligible for the
amount of time they were eligible for
the EFA or they could say I'm no longer
eligible for receiving new funds in the
EFA but I can still use my balance for
educational expenses beyond that I I
think that's the one thing that I did
not get an answer to yet and so you have
to separate out in your mind the
payments from the use okay right right
because you might be eligible for an
installment right and your use of
it you know think about it your use
could go this way forward right
regardless of when your payment when you
receive it is when you're eligible does
that make sense okay does that help you
and the family actually has the option
they wrote in the law to say I want to
Forfeit which actually is what most
people do they say I'm I'm leaving back
then the answer to what I asked would be
that the payments are based on the
current eligibility of the student
correct but if the student has the
ability to retain because they've been
in the phase for one year and they have
not graduated yet yes then they do have
the option of expending those remaining
balances in the accounts for educational
expenses further down the road you have
it exactly right yes I just wanted to
make sure that we're all on the same
page does that also answer your question
might answer the question but it's it's
you may not it's no no it's I think we
cannot uh expect that we'll all
necessarily agree with the legislation
for now but I just wanted to make sure
that our understanding of what goes on
we are on the same page I'm sure that
there will be places where we'll
continue to disagree over it that's
that's fine but yes and to that end
there was some Surprise by the dollar
amount that we refunded right and so you
can see in that to your point
representative Murray remember you said
oh wow that's you know it's almost a
million dollars that we sent back I mean
that's famili saying we don't we want to
Forfeit or we've exited or so it is a
substantial amount of money that we're
sweeping from the accounts and sending
back if you look at that it'd be hard to
imagine this scenario again why it was
kind of a uh unusual for us to suggest
that they that they were just rolling it
and rolling it that's it's not something
we generally see since it's 2:05 we do
have time and I apologize to the people
in the back of the room that came here
for the 2 p.m. trust me we are trying to
give everybody their time and we will
but we are trying to wrap this up
expeditiously but please continue to uh
answer question so speaking to that 1
million or whatever amount of money is
hanging around somewhere to to be
returned the return money or the carried
forward you have money uhhuh somewhere
and I'm sorry I missed the beginning so
I don't know if it's held by so take a
look at this page 16 in your packet and
you can also see the carry forward
balance there and the amount that was
returned so if you want to talk in real
dollars what I want to know is where is
there any interest acred no it's
non-interest bearing that's required by
our contract for whom for anyone it's in
FBO for the state so the money is held
in a for the benefit of the state
account that's non-interest
bearing yeah we're we're a we're a pass
through entity we don't we don't earn
interest on right State money that's
right what about the wallet accounts do
the wallet accounts are virtual money so
the money sits in the FBO for the
benefit of the state account until we've
said yes to an order then it would go
from there to the provider education
provider so neither you nor the parents
get a scent of Interest yeah the right
the the money in the accounts is virtual
they're looking at their balance and
creating transactions then the
transactions are filled on the back end
so the money
isn't there technically it's virtual man
you like you'd look at your Online
Banking balance it's a sweet deal for
the state well it would be great I mean
the state should earn interest I'm just
going to say the state should be earning
no one is earning interest I think
that's a discussion we'll have with the
treasurer yeah well they put in the
contract non-interest bearing fbl
account so that's how it's sitting there
we do also have a service on it for iny
which is means it's FDIC
insured okay so the whole balance is
FDIC insured for the entire amount of it
and it's all in an FBO for the state
okay please proceed representative Kelly
okay see I I think I think I'll leave it
there because I'm not sure what we so
please by all means seriously yeah just
you know more I moving towards the end
so in 25 and
26 um the expenditure expected
expenditures you show me what sheet
you're looking at okay good so that you
told me you want us to bring projections
okay so that's our sheet where we
question did projections based on what
we think it would look like if it was
Universal representative Murray just so
you know so this is our guess for what
the enrollment would look like if your
if the legislature chose to make the
program universal access be an
additional $220
million this is so if you use the top
corner you can see our current
enrollment see for 24 25 that's our
current enrollment for 25 26 that's what
we think will happen if you make it
Universal that's what we think the
increase will be you're expecting a 50%
increase from 8,000 students to an
additional 4,000 students if we're
looking at the same little chart so
you're underneath you're looking at the
400 Mill 40 million now uh going up to a
little over $60 million so a $20 million
increase in the program that's my guess
yes this is these are my best guesses
based on our existing uptake rates and
our current enrollment so yeah this year
we have
5884 this that's these are my guesses
Pro does this assume that it would be
Universal immed iately because what what
the house passed is not Universal in the
first year this is my scenario for
Universal immediately so this would be
Universal July 1st that's what you think
would happen yes okay that's right okay
so I I would BR I brought those because
I thought that's what you guys wanted so
no it's I I just want to make sure we
are all reading it the same way we
appreciate the effort but I just don't
want to what you know the Eternal
question is it for the year is it for
the banian is it assuming this St date
or that St date yes so this is a full
Universal projection July 1 correct okay
I got it any further questions from the
committee I want to make sure go ahead
please representative hacken Phillips
thank you i' I'm very pleased to learn
so much about um your processes and uh
more about the program itself um I just
as a lawyer I'm always paid to think
well I used to be paid to think about
worst case scenarios um you can talk to
Matt yeah and you know how you kind of
hedge hedge your buts and try to prepare
for thing the unknown for possible
scenarios within existing law that may
um allow for abuse of the program and um
I keep coming back to
the to the concern in particular to the
marketplace direct um you know payments
when the orders are approved you know
what what is there stop a parent from
you know reversing the order after it's
approved and returning the item and
great question what what furthermore how
would you ever know if that were to
happen um my constituents are concerned
that there may be families who are
reporting one thing up front and using
the funds for another thing behind and
this is what class wallet is actually
good for representative so when you're
processing something through this
virtual digital wallet you actually
don't get the receipt so you can't do a
return if you want to do a return you
have to go back through class wallet
they do the return for you and then the
vendor puts the money right into the
class Wallet account so that's why this
closed loop system is so useful so there
is no refund scam where you can buy
stuff from the store with a voucher and
return it for cash yes that's right
there's no you can't do that so because
the Fulfillment is done by class wallet
inside of that digital wallet you can
only ever put the money back in there
and so that's why we use this closed
loop system yeah I just um I'm pleased
to hear that about the closed system you
know I'm just um concerned about things
outside of that Clos system um so for
instance like a parent were to buy a
very expensive educational um printed
material and then um you know have the
approval process and you know we don't
know if that book is returned and the
cash is you know taken out that that
seems to me that's a vulnerability they
can't return I mean they would you could
maybe return something for store credit
but you couldn't get cash because if you
did a return it would go back into the
digital wall I think the representative
is more concerned about a parent buying
a really expensive book and then turning
around and selling it for cash to their
neighbor or what not but yeah no I
understand the concern yeah I mean I
think there's definitely vulnerabilities
here um re yeah there's real there's
really no mechanism for you to know if
that's happening so so we deployed an
anonymous fraud reporting tool and
hotline that was one of the me ask if
there is a mechanism we were you know
that was very important to us we you
know we established that um anyone can
you know if you have documentation that
that if you have
uh an allegation that you want to make
you can do that anonymously us the
online web tool you can call into the
the the 1800 number and make those
allegations upload your documentation
and then we'll obviously take those
those concerns very seriously well we
could send someone to the we could
report them yeah absolutely and we can
kick them out of the program if that you
know if we had that doc documentation so
we are we are there we you know we we
have to be good stewards of this program
and those parents you know misuse in in
intentional you suspected intentional
use you know those are the things that
keep me up at night um I'm a worry wart
so you know as the rules guy yeah I mean
I think the problem with this system is
that it it depends on a third party
reporting knowing who to report to to
report it to the right place and then
for it to have evidence to be able to be
followed up upon in such a manner that
makes sense for you I I just think
there's a lot of wh ifs along that
decision tree or proc process tree that
um provides opportunity for none of that
to take place so I just I'm a little
concerned about uh you
know the vulnerabilities for this
program to be abused no I I agree and
but I think that that that could be you
know the same with almost any other
program but we're certainly willing to
take any feedback that you have um any
you know if you propose legislation and
you have other mechanisms that you feel
would be appropriate uh we will
absolutely Implement anything that you
decide all said yeah I mean I'm just
thinking earlier to today's discussion
with representative wer or chair wier's
concerns about abuse of the tan program
or the wick program and how there are
certain guidelines in place to control
those programs but it doesn't feel like
we I think even those programs control
what you can buy they cannot possibly
control what you do with the items that
you bought y frankly I could see the
same thing if we are really hypothetical
here happening with textbooks I get from
my public school and so on I mean it's
you know I I hear you but I I don't know
if you have anything else to add on this
right now no I just wanted to know if
you had any questions about my
projection scenario but that's it any
any further questions I'm just I'm I I
want to make sure we have all the time
but again we do have a large number of
people that's waiting they're all behind
us and we are all well we are past their
time thank you so much for asking us are
we good yeah our our information is
available if you have other questions
really appreciate it thank you and with
this I'm going to declare this public uh
this uh work work session closed and in
exactly 1 minute we'll start uh the new
work session because somebody needs one
minute
oops e
okay it is 2:17 so we will start the uh
work session on public
transportation again my thanks to
everybody who showed up and again my
apologies that we are a few minutes
behind
schedule we try really hard to listen to
everybody and uh the committee had lots
of questions on the previous topic which
is great so again thank you for your
patience I want to remind everyone that
this being a work session we are um
slightly Limited in terms of how many
people we can listen to so I would
really appreciate it if you would make
every effort to be reasonably brief and
uh you know be able to answer the
questions and please I know that you all
have important things to say but let's
try not repeating things that may have
been said by a previous speaker feel
free to say I agree with those remarks
and I want to add my stuff and other
than that uh Mr landan who was
officially on the list here
uh Mr
Nichols prob a good place to start yeah
thank you and welcome
uh my name is rad Nichols I'm the
executive director at Coast uh we're the
public transit system in the seast area
I'm also the chairman of the New
Hampshire Transit Association and I
appreciate the opportunity to come and
speak before you today um uh we've never
had a that I'm aware of I've been
working in this field for 28 years here
in New Hampshire I don't think we've
ever had a budget work session on public
transit so thank you for the opportunity
um I I hope that we can highlight the
positive economic and social benefits
that public transit brings to New
Hampshire uh and uh talk about how State
investment can strengthen our e our
economy while also supporting our most
vulnerable
residents uh public transit represents
an important segment of New Hampshire's
economy and plays a significant role in
our ongoing economic and social health
public transit services are provided
regionally in New Hampshire by eight
different organizations operating in 42
communities which comprise more than
half of the of the state's resident
population New Hampshire Transit
providers directly employ more than 300
individuals Statewide and we help to
drive pardon the pun uh the state's
economy by contributing an estimated one
point or an estimated $110 million uh
each year
a recent economic impact analysis
conducted in New Hampshire shows that
for every $1 invested in public transit
there's more than a $4 economic return
in the state economy in addition and
very importantly that $1 investment
leverages an equal amount of federal
funds already allocated and ready to be
put in use in New Hampshire how does
public transit have such a significant
economic impact by harnessing the power
of connecting people with the
opportunities they need to success s
succeed personally and contribute
economically public transit connects New
Hampshire's Workforce to jobs people
like a restaurant worker who lives in
Lebanon and works in Hanover and uses
Advanced transit to access work public
transit connects students who are
tomorrow's Workforce to educational
opportunities people like the student
who uses nashwa transit system to attend
the Nashville community college to
become an air traffic controller public
transit is an affordable connection
ction between Workforce housing jobs and
Workforce training opportunities which
are increasingly located further apart
from one another due to the housing
shortage we live in a graying State and
the state plan on Aging has identified
Transportation was the number one reason
seniors in New Hampshire were not able
to access the services they
needed making sure seniors can get where
they need to go has significant economic
implications the AARP longevity Outlook
from 2018 identified that while the 50
plus population accounted for 41% of the
state's population it contributed nearly
47% or 42 billion of the state's total
GDP public transit also supports New
Hampshire's most V vulnerable residents
by providing Ada mandated services for
individuals living with disabilities
public transit allows them to to access
Support Services health care and
employment opportunities these are
people like the young woman who we
transport in Dober who uh Works uh uses
our Paratransit services to get her to
her job at the YMCA
Portsmouth on average between 20 to 30%
of riders of our Riders would not be
able to make their trip without public
transportation in in state fiscal year
2023 more than 2.1 million trips were
taken on public transit in New Hampshire
by workers students seniors families and
individuals living with disabilities in
state fiscal year 24 that number grew by
18.2% to over 2.5 million trips to work
school medical appointments shopping
social and recreational
activities um this afternoon I'm pleased
to be joined by representatives from a a
broad array of uh service providers uh
industry across the state and hopefully
they'll get an opportunity to uh share
with you as well so how can public
transit help the state achieve its
economic and social goals in the coming
budget cycle
as you take up the work of crafting the
state's next budget I encourage the
committee to consider the difference
between State spending and a state
investment as it relates to public
transit spending infers a net drain
while with investment there's an
expectation of a return in this budget
cycle where difficult choices must be
made investing in public transit can
help sustain and grow our state economy
while supporting Granite Staters that
need us the most it's the proverbial yet
often elusive win-win
proposition the state invested in public
transit operations in state fiscal year
with $600,000 in funding and increased
that to 1.68 million in state fiscal
year
25 the return on that increased
investment is already measurable uh that
investment helped public transit
operator operators expand Services
growing ridership by over 38 385,000
rides in state fiscal year 24 and
ridership has continued to experience
strong growth in state fiscal year
25 and more Riders translates to more
economic activity as we look down the
road ahead there's a direct correlation
between affordably connecting housing
jobs and Workforce training
opportunities across the state and our
ability to sustain Economic Development
so that public transit operators across
New Hampshire can continue to support
and further grow the state's economy the
New Hampshire Transit associ Association
is advocating for investment of $6.8
million of State operating support in
the state fiscal year 2627 budget we
also ask that state operating match be
clarified as eligible to be used not
only to leverage FTA operating expenses
at a one to1 ratio but also for those
eligible FTA operating expenses with a
very advantageous 4:1 match ratio that's
Federal to local uh these include
expenses associated with Ada operations
preventative maintenance planning
Mobility management and for Rural
agencies
Administration investment by the state
at this level will activate additional
investment from the Federal Transit
Administration by opening access to a
minimum of another $6.8 million of
already allocated Federal funding for
the state these are FDA funds that
require non us doot matching funds in
order to be put to use connecting our
residents so the state there's an
immediate return to that state
investment uh with the federal
government
participating we should always be
looking for ways to do more with the
resources we have in order to support
our economy and the New Hampshire
residents public transit touches every
segment of the state's economy gen
directly impacting the lives of hundreds
of thousands of granite sters investment
in public transit makes good Financial
sense and good social sense local
communities around New Hampshire are
already investing
in the power of public transit to drive
their economies and support their
residents we invite the state to join
them as near equal Partners I know
together we can do even more on behalf
of the association and our members I
thank you for your time and opportunity
to speak today thank you so much and
obviously questions from the committee
members sure two two things um do you
have those numbers that we hand out I
can barely type words never mind
I have so I have a letter that follows
my testimony I also have a flyer that we
use to maybe email the electronic
version to Mr landrian he would be able
to distribute it to us instead of making
paper copies I can do both I have the
paper here for you both are great I'll
take the paper yeah but if you could
still email the electronic version there
are some of us who only look at
electronic documents because of the
weight of paper and all happy too thank
you as you see I'm not of them
but and I just I wanted to point out it
to um just have you sort of state it in
a different way when you talk of the
impact this has on hundreds of thousands
of granite Staters uh we're about 1.2
million in the state so you're looking
at are we looking at 10% of people who
are impacted uh 20% of the people I mean
I'd just like to the percentage of the
number of granite Staters who take
advantage of this when you said the
hundreds of thousands that's a large
chunk of the New Hampshire population
that relies on this correct directly
impacted I think is probably more than
the 10% indirectly uh gets us into the
hundreds of thousands absolutely so um
just as just to build on representative
M's question um I know you said you are
offering services to you know around
half the population or a bit over half
um and you gave us a number of trips in
terms of do you have any way of
determining how many people took those
trips because of obviously somebody
could take a trip of every day somebody
could just take a trip every 3 months I
figure with public transportation it
would be darn hard to keep track of that
but do you have any light you can shed
into that at least an educated guess you
are correct that's really hard for us to
track yeah people get on the bus right
we don't uh when someone boards our bus
we don't necessarily know who they are
nor nor should we right so we start to
begin to recognize people when they're
regular Riders um on on our so that's on
our fixed route system so our you know
the traditional bus system that you
think of in the in the city right uh on
the demand response side so this is tend
to be services for older adults
individuals with disabilities um we do
know uh numbers there I I I don't have
that stat but I can get that stat for
you that would be much appreciated and
again email it to Mr landrian and he
will share it with everybody on the
committee look even if it's in
incomplete data is still better than no
data so we can you know we can work with
what we got and the town of Windham has
a you know similar service where the
town has a few cars driven by volunteer
drivers to offer on Demand right so I'm
slightly familiar with how that works on
a small scale but obviously you guys are
operating at a much larger scale so that
knowledge would be useful to the
committee thank
you further questions please
representative hacken Phillips
um as a reminder Could you um summarize
the eight Regional Transit could you
remind us where they are sure thank you
absolutely so I'll I'll start from the
north uh Tri County cap uh in uh Berlin
gorm area uh then we have advanced
transit in the Upper Valley we have
conquered area transit in conquered and
surrounding communities we have the MTA
man Manchester Transit Authority in
Manchester and the surrounding
communities um we have uh Sullivan
County transportation Newport Claremont
area we have uh HCS which operates over
in Keen we have nashille transit system
uh and we have uh Coast I think I
covered
everybody thank
you I thought we were not supposed to
put them on the spot like that sorry
that's really good memory I'm prepared
good job and another Fout Mr um chair
please so I know in the um in the
department of transportation's unfunded
um line item they were hoping to get a
match of 1.7 million per year um in the
budget and that was not included in the
governor's um in the governor's budget
this round um I'm wondering if you'd
care to comment on um you know what it
what the impact will be if there are no
State dollars coming to transit in the
vium and I'm wondering if you could also
comment on um you know kind of
contingency plans or alternative
suggestions that you might be thinking
through what are the scenarios your
groups are worried about and thinking
about so the the state had put in uh in
their
uh blank the right alternative needs
budget altern
prioritized prioritized needs budget
request uh for 3.4 million which would
have essentially level funded us at the
state fiscal year 25 amount um that that
that's sort of a a bare minimum um we
are coming in asking for twice that
amount because we're hoping to match um
we're hoping the state can can become a
near equal partner with all of the
communities that are funding public
transit to allow us to access all of our
Rural and small Urban funding that's
coming into the state from the Federal
Transit
Administration um if I can I can speak
for Coast on the question you raised
we're all unique and individual for
Coast um we we may need to look at
additional means testing uh for some of
our folks who qualify for our Ada
Services um that that may mean some
folks who've qualified as eligible would
no longer be eligible um that's our
biggest cost center at Coast is is those
services for individuals with
disabilities um just to briefly
interject I think you mentioned earlier
that those would be eligible for a 4 to1
Federal to local match rather than the
normal one to1 or did I am I putting
together things that shouldn't go
together um no you can put it together
but the but the federal funds that are
allocated to us
directly um we can we can only use 10%
of that allocation to go towards those
Ada expenses at 4 to1 above that which
we are well above that we're about 25%
of our operating budget goes to that
cost center above that it's a one: one
match
ratio um so that's one area where um we
could potentially affect some uh some
cost reductions another area uh would be
probably one or two of our routs that we
we would have to eliminate or consider
eliminating um as well as probably
reducing the span of service on any uh
service day we currently operate as late
as 10:00 at night we probably would look
at scaling back to somewhere being our
last runs of the of the day probably
departing around 7 so off the road by 8
um we might have to consider Saturday
changes to our Saturday Services as well
it's it's for us at Coast with the
federal match it's about a 10% hit to
our budget we have an $8.2 million
budget this year so it's it's
significant um and that's you know
that's
$389,000 a year from the
state annually so you know it's it's
$800,000 uh thereabouts of lost revenues
each year of the two years
further questions from the committee
okay so then thank you so much we
appreciate it now the general rule of
thumb for work sessions is that only the
people invited are uh you know expected
to speak but we do have a lot of people
and we do still have a little bit of
time with a agreement of the members of
the committee I'd like to you know give
a few other people an opportunity if you
have something to add try to negotiate
between yourselves because God knows
don't make me pick but if you want to
maybe come up in two or three together
and give us a bit more we appreciate it
and again if if somebody's starting to
have a schedule challenge please let me
know oh if we do have do here could I
ask do to uh prepare to get on the you
know q and we we'll have you next sorry
to to be clear I forgot you guys were in
the room or I would have asked you next
so my apologies for that it's on me
thank
you uh thank you Mr chairman my name is
Steve Workman I'm the director of
Transport New Hampshire so
transport Workman w r k m
an um transport New Hampshire is a
Statewide um advocacy technical
assistance that works across all modes
to support all modes of transportation
so I do not provide direct service in
other words I don't have a horse in this
race so my remarks today first I want to
acknowledge and support the things that
uh rad just shared with you um and I
won't repeat those what I want to do is
walk through my perspective on where
we're at right now but then I want to
talk about some of the national picture
and potential solutions that I think
this committee could benefit from as it
tries to balance
this so the first question I'd ask is
what part of our daily life doesn't
involve transportation and I remind you
walking is a mode of
transportation think what it took to get
onto this floor of the building and the
eom accomodations so as mobile Transit
people we have to prepare for all of
those different things but as we think
about how that flows through all sectors
of public life then that should compel
us to think more holistically about this
in other words not in
silos and once we start to do that we
recognize that you cannot talk about
affordable housing unless you are
dealing with public
transportation you cannot talk about
Recovery Services you can not talk about
people that are coming out of the
correctional
facilities about them not recidivism you
can't address those things if we haven't
solved for basic Transportation it is a
basic need ultimately now on the other
hand Granite Staters are fiercely
independent that's not news to
you until they're
not and the fact is that we are fiercely
independent but as we age and as as life
happens to us we find ourselves in a
position that we suddenly are desperate
for services that we thought we never
were going to pay for and we did not
want to
fund as somebody that has has
experienced that personally both with
aging parents and also a close family
friend of mine uh who is Young and
experiencing endstage renal failure and
is on
dialysis when the crisis hits that's not
the time to be looking around and
praying that our leaders put a system in
place to support
us and I think we need to think about
that I'm going to talk a little later
about some of these solutions that come
out of the federal level that'll help us
think about how can we do that then how
can we move things across state agencies
and have a more comprehensive
discussion so the first piece the
elimination of in the governor's budget
of operating funds feels like a colossal
setback and I say that because in my
time and I I came onto this scene in
2019 in my time I have w wied my
colleagues that are providing
transportation services rise to the
occasion I have seen do become a partner
in this work where they come to us and
we try to find innovative solutions and
strategies and boy we try to stretch a
nickel as far as we possibly
can in the last funding by Anum we had a
bipartisan agreement that allowed us to
bring in an influx of money desperately
needed and as rad explained in his
remarks this is money that is matching
federal funds that the state of New
Hampshire is entitled to and I don't
know about you but I can't sleep at
night thinking we're leaving money on
the table when I know for certain that
we have residents in our state that have
needs so I want to make sure that nobody
is operating under the illusion that in
eliminating that it was a one-off that
it solved the problem because it didn't
our providers have costs just like any
of us that run a household any of us
that run a business and those those
costs are inflating
continually already municipalities are
contributing millions of dollars to help
us with match and we absolutely expect
that to continue we are absolutely
reaching out to charitable sources of
funding Chambers of Commerce businesses
to build relationships so they can help
support our TR basic transportation
system the problem is without State
funding we are truly dead in the water
the majority of the expenses that ever
come before you in the form of a budget
are federal pass through dollars and
unfortunately that places New Hampshire
at the bottom of the list in the in the
bottom category of the list of per
capita expenses Nationwide that we've
invested in Community Transportation
public transit now I know we don't want
to compare ourselves to other states
we're New Hampshire we know our business
but we aren't low because we've done
such an effective and efficient job of
supplying these it's because we've
neglected some of these needs
so in the National picture things are
getting very difficult I'm not
expressing an opinion one way or the
other but they are difficult right now
it is unclear whether our federal
funding streams and then discretionary
grants that also play a major role in
delivering these services are going to
be there in the future we have reason to
believe that they will we have reason to
believe that a continuing resolution
should get us a little further down the
road the problem is we don't have
guarantees and as our as our federal
partners are trying to figure out what's
legal who can do what it's providers
back here and my colleagues these are
not operations that are bloated and can
sustain three six months at this point
we're still talking about uncertainties
not yet about actual Cuts right that is
correct just wanting to make sure that
and I know that question would be asked
anyway so we may as well get ahead of it
yeah we just get right out there so yes
these are the things that we're looking
at and so our concern is as you think
about these agencies any potential
impact at that level could have a
catastrophic effect and this brings us
back to the state so if the state has
sort of absolved itself and step back
from being responsible and part of this
equation and the FEDS some way shape or
form limit money coming into our state
we've got a problem because I can tell
you the property tax base cannot respond
to this and cannot make up the
difference and then again we're leaving
money on the table
so in the interest of time I want to
jump to a solution piece and this comes
out of some of the work I've done
previously with Federal technical
assistance centers there's something
called the federal coordination Council
for Access and Mobility or Camp it
identifies 130 Federal programs that are
able to provide funding for
transportation for people with
disabilities older adults and or IND
individuals of low
income does anyone want to guess which
federal agency has the most
Transportation dollars for these human
transportation services and let me give
you a hint it's not
usdot going to giv the Pentagon but fine
not for human transportation services um
it's actually Health and Human Services
they have 66 of those programs that I
just referenced then do has 12 HUD has
12 the Department of Labor has 11 the
Department of Justice has 10 education
has 10 and the VA has three
that just gives you a sense of the
potential each one of these programs
have Federal pass through dollars that
arrive in our state but what we do is
and it makes sense we got to figure this
out so it gets distributed into these
different agencies or
silos the work for us is to be more
creative and Innovative with that how
can we cross sector how can we work
between agencies and find a way to share
those resources in a way that one isn't
suffering but we are actually becoming
more efficient in Service delivery and
we're actually advancing um
opportunities where we're both meeting
our mission see right now I my
colleagues in the state we have been
actively trying to be ambassadors of the
ccam solutions that are out there of our
own coordination work within the state
but if the doors don't open to us we
can't have that
conversation so I think this the
legislature in particular but all of our
elected officials have a core
responsibility it's to create the
environment where this type of cross
agency cross sector coordination and
working together is actually the rule
not the exception but I will tell you
and I I can tell you this because I've
seen it in other states it does not
happen without you building that in so
rather than you doing the heavy lift of
the budget this year and then the next
cycle comes along and you start all over
again we've got to start thinking how we
can make our federal dollars work harder
for us New Hampshire and we stand ready
to help with that in fact uh chairman
Nicholls and myself we have a pending uh
request into the governor's office to
discuss not just the funding but to
discuss these opportunities um it seems
like with Governor aot's uh Commission
on government efficiency it sounds like
I'm talking about something that's ready
made for them to look at so the reason I
wanted to bring this to you today was to
remind you to think a little bit outside
of the box ccam
has given us the permission structure
and the process for figuring out how we
can leverage our federal funds better
and in this case of course I'm talking
about transportation
services so again to allow other more
time for the committee I would just
close by saying I do support um both of
the requests that chairman Nichols we
weren't exctly expecting you to oppose
it you would at this point um but I'm
going to add one more thing and that is
help us create that environment as
elected officials where we have marching
orders who are state employees and those
of us that are working out here in the
spaces between to connect give us the
marching orders and then call on us I
will happily drive up here my colleagues
will to continue to work with you it is
impossible to do your job and to
understand all the nuances of things
that we do on a daily basis that's why
we have work sessions thank you
appreciate it and if we could have
questions by means can you just send the
name of the program or something say I
don't type so coordination Council
access and Mobility the federal thing as
a matter of fact I'll do one better I
will send you a copy uh for the
committee that actually is a PowerPoint
of federal uh ccam it'll map it out and
and you'll have it so you can look at
and I'm happy to answer more
questions I take notes exactly because I
don't remember everything so if we could
have the Department of Transportation
step up and again I apologize for
completely forgetting you were here it's
U rude of me so please go ahead and do
introduce yourself yes so for the record
my name is Shelley Winters I'm the
director of the division of Aeronautics
Rail and Transit at the Department of
Transportation was able to sit before
you earlier this week and talk about um
our budget along with commissioner Cass
um obviously we're talking about
accounting unit 2916 which is the public
transportation budget and particularly
um class 73 funds um I will you know
happily yield any time that you were
going to give to me to uh our Transit
providers who can probably more
eloquently contextualize the impacts I
know we spoke overarchingly ear earlier
this week we're certainly advocates for
public transit um as some of our
colleagues said we do feel it's an
investment in our um State and in our
community and a lot of people around the
state are employed by um or can be
employed as a result of being able to
use this uh access to medical
appointments recreational nutrition I
mean you name it everything that we do
in the State uh is a result in a large
part to public Transit the affected
agencies that Mr Nichols spoke about
moved about 2 million people last year
to your question unique Riders that's
difficult for the agencies to quantify
but if you just look at Raw numbers
based on the population and knowing a
lot of these people are probably Riders
are probably Transit dependent that
would be a lot of lost even if you use
the 10% that that rad that's that's
200,000 um R frankly every ride is
important whether it's repeated riders
or not I mean you know correct just to
quickly before I lose personally that
train of thought the last comments about
the almost 100 or more Federal programs
that may be available which to me sounds
like a federal problem but in the
meantime it could also be an opportunity
any thoughts on what support the
department may need in order to better
navigate those uh complicated mazes
bureaucratic mazes uh in DC yeah I I
think we've been as as was said we're
we've been doing better as of late we
have a Statewide coordinating Council
for Community Transportation which is
established under statute here in the
state and we have eight Regional
coordinating councils um the group
convenes monthly they in fact they met
yesterday um the same day that the New
Hampshire Transit Association convenes
the department sends staff to those
meetings we are a listed participant as
well as health and human services and a
few other state agencies to to sit on
the State Coordinating Council and we're
trying to work together to to demystify
the funding from a federal level and the
Trickle down to the state level um in
the past we've partnered with some other
state agencies to try to jointly fund
some Regional Mobility managers so
Within These eight um regions that we've
established under the state we've tried
to to fund and now the department is
solely funding them to help coordinate
services within those regions to have
one voice a unified voice that goes out
um looks for the funding sources um and
and tries to help agencies work together
where it's a Social Service Agency or
the shuttle you talked about in your
community to try to to link passengers
and how do you measure the effectiveness
of those programs and I know that I'm
kind of stepping into Uncharted
territories here but you tell me that
you want to create a new position
obviously my next question is how well
does it work and how would you know if
it's doing the job properly or not so
let me clarify those are not these are
not State positions these are um
positions that are embedded within the
the regions themselves the funding flows
through us so it's Federal Transit
Administration funding that flows from
us and they're not state employees um we
contract yeah but we support that
schedule so I still like to know if it
works or not that's great and that's why
I probably look over my shoulder to my
colleague but um Fred Butler is here and
we have through the State Coordinating
Council we have a um a group that is
working on performance measures to to
address concerns such as that um it's in
its infancy but we do have a a group
that's trying to prove the effectiveness
so Fred or someone from the SEC by by
the way try to avoid coming up I
wouldn't use the word concerns as much
it's just normal management of any
program we'd like to have some idea of
how effective it is because at the end
of the day you establish programs you
got to figure out which work and you
keep and which don't work and you
eliminate or replace or all that so you
know without accountability that it's
kind of hard to get any funding so you
know I appreciate the and sorry for
putting you on the spot but you were in
the room which was your first mistake go
ahead just introduce yourself yes there
we go oh uh yeah good afternoon thank
you um Fred Butler I'm the public
transportation administrator and uh we
have um largely and thanks to um Steve
Workman and and the collective efforts
at the SEC there's a there's a blueprint
for the mobility management Network as a
whole that lays out currently there are
13 performance measures or key
performance
indicators um ranges anything just from
the traditional ridership to the number
of partner Partners um brought to the
table that are Transportation providers
and just um other stakeholders that are
involved in within each region um we
have uh number of meetings uh Outreach
events that are that are held to make
people aware that there is um now there
are resources available for
transportation at the state and Regional
level um and again we we can send you
the blueprint but that that's the
essence of it we are never going to be
able to resist the temptation of more
information so feel free to send that to
Mr electronically so which is how we
like it anyway yeah again questions from
the committee I don't want to you know
hog everything uh representative uh oh
my God
Dy he spoken with her about a 100 times
so okay I have a question I don't do
public transportation I never have
because I live out in the boondoggle so
I have to have a car is there a fee for
people to use public
transportation it it varies by agency um
and part of the reason is the way the um
the federal funding is structured that
uh the the subsidy needs to have the
fairs netted out so there there's no way
to come up with enough match based on
fairs because it it just U it just
reduces the amount of federal subsidy
needed but you still have to come up
with that onetoone match so some agency
are fair free um several systems are
fair free so you you don't pay anything
you could ride any route all day and
others are you know a125 per ride or you
can buy a multide or a monthly pass so
again it's system by system based on the
eight agencies behind us but again
revenues um you know talking about
raising revenues to or fairs to try to
offset the loss of this it won't work
because as Fred was saying you net out
any Fair recovery before you have any
federal um funding participation
so and certainly let us know where you
live and we'll see if we have a program
that can benefit
you any other
questions okay so I appreciate it
anything else you'd like to add because
apparently we are good question wise but
if there was something you didn't get to
that should have been brought up this
would be the you know going going gone
moment just uh to to the point of the
discrepancy and what you saw in the
request for the budget of roughly 1.7
million in our additional needs and what
Mr Nicholls spoke about that the transit
agencies are advocating for that initial
um dollar amount we came up for the 1.7
was based on two years ago when we were
preparing the budget looking at the
increase federal funds that were coming
in through iiga and then commissioner at
at the time commissioner Sheen and I had
sat down and we were only looking to
request because we knew it was a tight
fiscal environment the incremental State
funds to access the new iiga increase
and so that's why we stuck with that
same methodology in this budget request
but we've certainly have heard from our
partners at nhta and the transit
agencies as a collective they have
always sought to request more funding
because even with these State funds that
we have of the 1.7 we're not fully um
drawing down on an annual basis our
funds from FTA so again they're here to
Advocate better based on their financial
situation and the the reality of the
local funding constraints that they're
facing and the department went in with
the methodology of incremental iig
funding so I just wanted to explain what
the discrepancy is and let them better
articulate the holistic need for the
larger funds of course there is always
that whole uh reality of the public
transportation and the reality of the
state budget that uh you know tend to go
head to head on this one so we're doing
the best we can but I obviously nobody
at this table can make Promises at this
stage we are trying that we can promise
so um there are about 5 minutes until
300 p.m. when we were planning to end
would it be okay to the committee to
suggest maybe one more uh person or
group of people speaks before we wrap it
up okay cool okay great so thank you so
much again really appreciate it and if
we could uh you know open the table to
uh somebody and or more than one person
who wants to uh join
please good afternoon
all Vice chair members of the committee
thank you so much for listening for
having us here uh my name is Dennis
Shanahan uh the deputy mayor of do I'm
also the the chairman of the board of
Coast uh in my very brief comments uh I
just want to do two things one is to
kind of personalize the impact of public
transit uh I I I think this is a story
uh and and thoughts that you've all had
I just want to make sure that they're
said out loud here I also want to
provide some perspective on the
municipalities uh involvement here so
winter budget addressed last month
governor aot was quoted as saying that
uh the first step in shaping the budget
was to address the most vulnerable those
with disabilities and suffering from
mental health challenges public transit
is available to all in New Hampshire
it's available to all Indo over but it
is well known that many riders that use
the service do that because that is
their only means of transportation uh
other than maybe a set of sneakers and a
pair of shoes uh public transit creates
opportunities for a most vulnerable
population to live full productive
rewarding lives while becoming important
parts of our community and that's really
the focus I I have in this and I'm
thinking of two uh DOA citizens that
I've come to know uh quite well over the
last couple of terms Katie and Alex uh
they are adults living with disabilities
uh they uh they are not in a position
where they can own and operate their own
car so they're they're very much relying
on public transit when uh when when
walking isn't going to be a solution uh
you think of a few days over the last
month but walking really would not have
been a solution uh for folks to go a
couple of miles it not only connects
them to their jobs the grocery stores
their workplaces uh but it also enables
them to become deeply involved in the
community and I've watched these two
really Blossom uh they're members of
Abel New Hampshire uh who do advocacy
for the disabled uh Alex has become uh a
chapter president uh and is an excellent
advocate for for the needs of the of the
disabled and I can't help but think that
a big part of that is being able for him
to have a full life to to go to work
every day to be able to go to the
grocery on his own grocery store on his
own um and using trans public
transportation is is is a key part of
that and that's the personalization of
it that really is important to me uh Mr
Les articulated the mission of the
transit systems and the impressive 400%
return on our federal state and local
funds that keep the systems moving so
imagine being one of the thousands of
our citizens across the state who every
day you walk over a couple blocks to the
bus stop and then tomorrow that bus
isn't going to run and it's not going to
run the next week or the month after you
and the impact on those folks so if we
lose public transit in this state and I
and I TR I'm an optimist I really am I
hate I hate being cynical uh but we do
talk quite a bit of a a spiral of death
that once you start peeling back Roots
peeling back times you lose ridership
which means you
lose some of the the fair the the fair
money that's coming in so you have to
peel back some more and and you could
eventually work yourself into that we've
been trying really hard uh to avoid that
and there was a a huge undertaking on
RAD and his staff's part uh five years
ago now uh to completely revamp the
system in the middle of the pandemic uh
to make it more efficient more effective
and they pulled that off uh just
flawlessly So currently cities and towns
in the SE coast region contribute
Millions per year to maintain our
regional public transit system Dover is
approaching a $600,000 a year uh amount
that we provide as partners with coast
and these have seen significant
increases over the last several years
double digit increases um obviously the
price of fuel has gone up the price of
parts for buses has gone up and we have
had to increase the pay that we pay our
drivers so that we can keep
them many of our drivers are need a
commercial driver's license those folks
are in high demand uh and it's really
hard to to to pay enough to to keep
folks around it can almost be a system
where they where a pass through for for
drivers so we did increase and I think
we've been successful in bumping up uh
the compensation a little bit
we and again we have asked had to ask
the municipalities like Dober Rochester
Portsmith uh Farmington summersworth New
Market ET to increase their
contributions uh some communities are
definitely telegraphing that they are
beginning to struggle with these
increases certainly the source of the
increas is when we have to turn to a
municipality when we turn to Dober and
say we're going to need an extra
$120,000 this year that's coming out of
property taxes it is coming out of uh
the ability of folks to stay in the
community so folks communities are
definitely struggling with that so
that's the community perspective with it
so we're all proud of the growth that
we've seen in New Hampshire continued
funding of public transit by all
stakeholders is vital to ensure all
segments of our population benefit from
the New Hampshire way so that's my
perspective of the community and and of
my good friends Alex and Katy yes uh my
name is Margaret Joyce I'm the president
of the greater do chamber of of Commerce
and I will uh be brief because I am not
as eloquent nor do I have statistics to
uh throw at you but I serve on the board
of Coast uh representing the six Sea
Coast Chambers of Commerce and my
colleague Bonnie McNair is here uh from
the summersworth chamber also a so co-
served community and I would like to
just point out uh in addition to the
wonderful stories we've heard about the
individual human impact this also has a
business impact our Collective members
from the six seast Chambers we've got
about 2,000 members they do represent a
lot of nonprofits including AEL um and
Coast has a program where they do give
passes to their clients uh to get to
recovery appointments to get to jobs to
get to hospital appointments but rad
also mentioned about a cutting service
and what that means think about
restaurants think about hotel workers
think about all the folks who work in
downtown uh Portsmouth who support the
tourism industry those businesses
contribute heavily to rooms of meals
Revenue if they can't get staff to come
to work work they have to C back hours
that has a direct impact on state
revenue uh in addition to these
businesses who rely on workers to get
there think about Great Bay Community
College we heard about the Nash student
who's studying to be an air traffic
controller Great Bay has programs that
are feeding uh the medical profession as
we know we have a real crisis in getting
healthc care workers our Chambers
represent uh at least three large
Healthcare networks Wentworth Douglas
exitor Hospital Portsmouth Regional we
depend on uh transportation to move
people around the Sea Coast and I can
only speak for the Sea Coast but um
you've heard from some others that this
is really a a Statewide issue I live in
an area where I depend on a car as well
um but I grew up in Boston and as a
student I took the tea into Boston every
day to get my education and I'm
extremely grateful that it was there for
me please go ahead anyone that's been
through the sheet anyone that's been
through leadership SE coost or
leadership here in the state understands
what you do and how difficult it is for
you to do what you're doing because we
have such a large State and we and our
population is not really concentrated in
the way that makes it easy to get people
to the places that they need to go so I
want to thank you for that and all that
you're doing to to get people to where
they need to go and they still have
problems there's a lot of problems that
that are out there so but thank you
thank
you so thank you really appreciate you
being here now it did occur to me that
we were planning to finish at 3: but we
were also planning to start at two so
maybe uh taking a few more minutes to
give room to to give time to the people
that made an effort to come here would
be a good idea again I I I I know that
I'm uh imposing on the Goodwill of the
committee but I that's why I keep asking
about it I you know would appreciate it
if we could um anybody else who would
like to add something
please I'm Terry pagee and I am the
transportation director for the
community action program for belnap and
marac counties here in conquer I I know
representative Bean because we work
together with belut County so nice to
see you representative Bean um I
completely support and Echo everything
that all the great colleagues that have
come before me to this table has SP has
said it's absolutely everything they
said is correct and I'm hoping to kind
of put a more local spin on it I'm uh
one of the smaller rural providers here
in the state so even though we work here
in conquer um we are still considered a
rural provider mainly because the
population density is still not that
great here in conquer itself so we go
quite a ways to be able to get people to
those connections that they need but
even though we're a small system um we
provided over 15,000 rides last year
which is pretty phenomenal when you
think about the small area that we have
within this conquered City itself for
toide that many rides um of that we had
106,000 that were on the fixed rout
system itself which is the bus that runs
the three buses that run here in conquer
and the biggest increase that we had
were the
9,588 rides on our demand response
system and those are the folks that are
the most vulnerable in my mind the folks
that are over the age of 60 or have a
disability that prevents them to getting
to that fixed rout bus and those are the
rides that really help them stay in
their homes and stay connected to their
communities and it doesn't get more
vital than that truly in my mind um our
roots are connected and and set up to be
able to connect folks from Workforce
housing particularly to uh employment
centers so we have here in the city we
have runs that go to Walmart and the
other retail um businesses up on the the
heights we have the manufacturing and
construction businesses out on Airport
Road and Penbrook road that we bring
folks to uh we have the state hospital
complex Hospital conquer hospital and
dhmc Clinic up on Pleasant Street we
also have nhti and all the retail
businesses down on Fort Eddie and then
of course Main Street conquered so we
tried to make sure that we were
connecting folks to the real areas of
business and commerce and and social
services that they need here in the city
and that's always foremost in our mind
is how are we going to efficiently and
appropriately get people where they need
to go um some of our regular workers are
going from those Workforce housing
complexes that we have down in Penacook
up to the hospital or up to the heights
to be able to work at Walmart or we're
transporting um inmates from the state
prison that are on work release from
there up to the manufacturing businesses
that are up on Airport Road and Penbrook
road so we're really making an impact in
those folks that need to get to work the
most because those are the folks that
honestly can't even afford a car or
don't have any way of being able to get
a car to get them to where they need to
go um the other piece that I really
wanted to make sure that you guys were
aware of and a couple of my colleagues
have touched on this is we only have 27
employees but they're very important
employees and we just barely two years
ago with the increase that we were able
to use because of the state match got
them to within range of the going wage
for a CDL driver we're not even really
close yet but we're almost there and
that actually helped us keep our staff
it kept our team together and it really
reduced the attrition that we had for
our staff to be able to keep these
Services running so when you talk about
not having that state match the impact
for us as such a small system is I'm
almost more than likely going to lose
staff because I'm not going to be able
to give them the the increase that they
need based on their increasing expenses
on a personal level as well I'll
probably have to cut a root and that's
really hard when you only have four
roots so it's it's an immediate impact
and I hope it helps frame some of the
discussion that we have in terms of how
it's going to immediately impact some of
the smaller systems that are running
here in the state so I thank you very
much for this time and I really
appreciate your efforts we appreciate
you being here and seriously look we
originally planned to have have a couple
of people talk right work session but it
is hard to uh see so many people come up
and not show them the consideration for
the time they put in coming here I we
may not be able to do that for everybody
and I hope you understand that you know
at the end of the day you know we only
have so many sure moments but every one
of those does help a lot in again if it
helps I think we all brought paper oh
please seriously any handouts that you
have please bring them to Mr landrian so
I do thank you all very much I really
appreciate thank you and if you have
anything that you didn't necessarily
have with you but you want to share with
a committee again Mr landrian is the
point of contact where if you send
something to him he will share it with
the committee it is best not to email an
individual Committee Member because then
you don't know if everybody else will
get the same thing and that creates
confusion in the committee where people
expect that everybody got it but nobody
so if if we communicate through Mr
landrian that Smooths out all the you
know po issues and um I think that we
should be able to accommodate at least
one more person if you want to jump in
please I'm not even going to make jokes
about the orange Badge go ahead okay so
um I'm from the New Hampshire Alliance
for healthy aging but I I will tell you
personally I've worked it's just not the
orange badge I've grown up in New
Hampshire I worked in New Hampshire I'm
so sorry I forgot I didn't catch your
name oh sorry so uh Judith Jones from
the New Hampshire Alliance for healthy
aging and new Futures and I've worked in
the area of elder law for over 25 years
in New Hampshire and um have grown up in
New Hampshire so um bring my heart and
passion to this group and what I really
appreciate about this group is the
intensity of your listening so I'm so
happy just to say uh a few words today
over the years as I've done this work
and listen to people aging when we do
surveys about what is the number one
need of folks who are aging in New
Hampshire the number one answer
repeatedly is
transportation and just want to
emphasize that today and you've heard so
many people talk about what are the
folks who need Transportation who are
aging needing it's groceries it's
medication it's doctor's appointments
and just to emphasize and be quick for
you some of the points that have been
raised is we're working hard in the
advocacy Community to promote Home and
Community Based care we want to decrease
the costs of nursing facilities care and
the HHS committee is going to hear about
that all the time but this is a
major um uh advance in New Hampshire
where we're promoting Home and Community
Based care without transportation those
advances that cost savings would go away
I'm uh learning more about
Transportation the nuts and bolts from
the folks today and really appreciate
the passion and the details behind it
and just want to tell you that the the
folks who are aging are relying on the
transportation and it is cost
effective thank you thank you questions
from the
committee okay thank you so because this
was a reasonably brief one we'll take
one more person and then we'll call it
off look I I I I don't want to move the
goal point but I'm moving them in your
favor so uh you
know but
seriously no no it's you come in and and
and seriously I think we'll we'll make
this the last testimony unless somebody
really has a critical thing to
say um Mr chair uh members of the
committee good afternoon my name is
danis Chamberlain and I am part of the
small But Mighty team at ATA outdoor Med
uh media in Greenland New Hampshire uh
I'm just here to share ATA outdoor
media and we're in Greenland New
Hampshire I'm here to share the benefit
that public transit systems provide our
business um and many others like it ATA
was established in
1992 and has partnered with Transit
providers across New England starting
with Coast as our very first partner and
we have since built decades long
relationships with the New Hampshire
transits both in rural and urban areas
throughout the state our mission is to
continue to network the public transit
providers um to maximize Financial
benefits for all systems by selling
advertising space on their buses and bus
shelters most of the revenue goes
directly to the transit providers to
reinvest in their systems while we
retain a commission to sustain ours we
have a symbiotic relationship um our
success depends on their success just as
they rely on us to generate funds we
rely on them to maintain a robust
transit system that will attract
advertisers uh we're a small business
like many across new Hampshire that
benefits directly from the relationship
we have with public transit systems
operating in our state um Additionally
the funds that we raised for most of the
transits can be used to elevate their
local match unlocking Federal resources
to sustain and expand vital services in
our
communities with the rising ridership
and the growing influx of new residents
uh securing these funds is essential not
only to maintain public transit but to
drive the expansion that helps our
communities thrive
Outdoor Advertising has seen tremendous
growth Nationwide across all media
formats in recent years with Transit
advertising leading the way as one of
the top growing sectors in 2024 uh
outdoor ad spend nationally hit a record
of $9.1
billion uh clearly reflecting its Rising
impact oh then you reach I'm
kidding um we see businesses of all
sizes increasingly uh turning to Transit
advertising as a powerful way to reach
Their audience uh demand in New England
uh Rose significantly last year and we
expect to see a boost uh for the
remainder of
2025 uh it's our hope that our Transit
Partners can continue to be fully
operational and able to expand their
reach into our communities as it will
help us to secure more advertising
contracts for them um while many of the
advertisers are National Brands and
Regional um buyers from banking uh educ
ation and healthare sectors transfer
advertising is also a vital cost
effective for New Hampshire
cost-effective solution for New
Hampshire small businesses and
nonprofits it offers a smart and
scalable way for them to stand out in
their communities putting their message
right in front of thousands of potential
customers every day right where it
matters most uh we educate advertisers
on the wide reach and Powerful impact uh
that tra Transit are of Transit
advertising and we also strive to help
the local businesses understand its full
circle benefits by advertising their
products and
services um on the buses they are only
they not only attract more customers but
they're also investing into their local
transit systems uh this in turn will
help strengthen public transportation
Drive the economic growth and enhances
Community
well-being and this is because public
transit is more than just a means of
transport ation it does fuel economies
multiple Studies have shown that every
dollar invested in public transit
generates significant economic returns
and it creates a ripple effect that
benefits residents businesses and entire
communities a strong public transit
network is essential for a thriving
forward moving Society uh to create such
an impact they obviously need proper
funding on behalf of the many small
businesses in New Hampshire uh that
benefit directly or in directly from
public transit systems I hope that you
will consider including sufficient State
funds to maximize uh the use of federal
funding allocated to our state to their
operations which will help grow public
transit and boost the New Hampshire
economy many thanks for your time thank
you well we can always promise we'll
consider things finding money is a
different question but we are trying any
questions from the committee M
representative Mur are you a thank you
are you for-profit or nonprofit We Are
for-profit
further questions from the committee go
ahead I absolutely love the idea that
you're doing that with these individuals
because you're getting the community uh
businesses to buy into those that
transportation and broadening that might
be an additional answer to to some of
the problems great idea thank you very
much we really um revamped our entire
marketing and way of being over the past
year and a half and really want to f
focus on the local businesses that it to
increase that full circle benefits so
winwin situations are fun exactly yep
absolutely um anybody else cool thank
you so one quick comment before we wrap
up unless we have further discussions
somebody earlier was mentioning that
they appreciate uh that we are actually
listening look here's the thing this is
the finance committee I know there are a
bunch of other policies committees and I
don't want to speak for those but in
here during this time of the year we are
here every day next week we are
scheduled to be here every day except
Tuesday and we are not here Tuesday
because it's the town election day and
traditionally you got to let people be
at their Town elections
so we spend a lot of hours doing this so
every minute is a lot has a lot of value
so we when we have the opportunity to
listen that's probably the only chance
we'll have so we really got it and we
appreciate again you being here and uh
any what let you know this being a work
session go ahead
ha can flates thank you Mr chair so um
as you all know I'm in Hanover which is
a part of the Upper Valley and our
regional transportation system is the
advanced transit
system and um from speaking with folks
um I guess last bani when we were going
through the iig ja match um discussion
um I do remember that there was um a
larger uptick
uh with student ridership um and um
worker ridership in the oper Valley that
um was tied um to kind of like
postco Trends and um the other thing
that was part of that discussion was um
medical transportation for visits to the
obviously the large
dhmc and other
um uh like you know heater road offices
Etc um in the Upper Valley so um elpac
day anyway there's several several um DH
little stops along the way um between
Claremont and the Upper Valley that's
served and when I think um to the
discussion that we reviewed at the time
there was a lot of um concern about
there's no way to get these patients out
of the hospital who no longer require
inpatient care home because they don't
have a means of trans
transportation and that these Services
um through the federal um assistance
program I think there are some grants
available to help people get gas cards
or to help people you know find
Transportation home from the hospital to
open the beds to kind of unclog the
system so when I think about um the
greater Health Care system and how it's
delivered here in the state of New
Hampshire transportation is
um uh intricately entwined in that that
um ability to serve Granite Staters so
you know when one bed is full with
someone who can't leave that means
there's someone waiting outside the
hospital trying to receive care but
can't get it so you know this this
sounds like a small problem for the
Upper Valley but then when you think
about hospitals diversions to other
hospitals outside the Upper Valley then
you're really talking about this
Transportation problem help hurting
other hospitals outside of our region
and then you know those beds get full so
this really is a
connected issue for for more than just
what we're talking about just driving
getting people to work or whatever I
mean it's it this is a
compounding um piece of the fabric of
our of our state's day-to-day business
and um and the way people live and um I
just like to remind all of us that um
while it seems like maybe you don't use
Transit on a day-to-day basis for
personal use that there still is an
effect on your personal life so um no I
think we all appreciate the reminder of
the complexities and the
interconnectedness of uh today's society
whether it's New Hampshire or other
states I mean this is why it's so darn
hard to make policy because you have all
those levels you can push and God knows
what happens if you push this one but
you don't push yeah I I do think um you
know the concerns about the Federal
funding matches and the concerns uh with
Federal funding Healthcare matches as
well you know all these threads are held
together very um delicately and when you
pull one it's going to affect all so we
really um I think this is this should be
a an important disc thing to keep in
mind when we get to the negotiation
phase of course we've been negotiating
for a
month fully agreed and seriously I I
shouldn't be overly factious but yeah we
haven't got we are still gathering
information and trying to get to the
actual sausage making but we are pretty
darn close to that stage so uh not much
left cool any other comments from the
members of the
committee great then our next meeting is
on Monday as you uh surely know and then
on Wednesday and then on Thursday we
have a session day and on Friday we meet
again so U don't make any holiday plans
for a while than thank you uh with this
I will call the uh work session closed
at 3:23 p.m. and again thanks to
everybody who attended we really
appreciate it thank you